[Musique]
André Cheng, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Et bien, je m'appelle André Chieng.
Je suis un euh français d'origine
chinoise né à
Marseille, ce qui explique que j'ai
suivi toute ma
jeunesse une éducation française à
l'école et chinoise en famille.
Donc c'est comme ça j'ai vécu pendant
les 20 premières années de ma vie et
assez naturellement après la fin de mes
études, je suis allé passer un certain
temps en Chine et j'ai fait toute ma
carrière professionnelle en dirigeant
une société dont la vocation était de
permettre de
rapprocher les sociétés françaises et
chinoises et en particulier aider les
sociétés françaises à s'implanter en
Chine.
Vous avez fait quoi comme étude ?
Alors, j'ai fait euh l'école
polytechnique et ensuite j'ai complété
par des études à Science Po et à l'INSA,
l'école de la statistique de l'INS.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler Chine bien
entendu. On va parler guerre économique,
on va parler peut-être manœuvre, guerre
commerciale, Taiwan et j'en passe.
Allons-y. André, est-ce qu'il faut avoir
peur de la Chine ?
Il ne faut surtout pas avoir peur de la
Chine. Donc euh la Chine, vous le savez,
euh est un pays, on le répète parfois,
mais pas suffisamment, est un pays qui
euh en réalité n'a jamais vraiment mené
de guerre à l'extérieur. Savez-vous
quelle est la dernière fois où l'armée
chinoise est sortie de ces frontières ?
Bah, en mer de Chine récemment, ils
arrosent tous les bateaux.
C'est pas de la guerre déclarée, mais
c'est une revendication au rouleau
compresseur. Alors alors cette
revendication remonte à très loin donc
on ne se rend pas compte mais en fait au
19e siècle c'était déjà le cas. Bon,
mais l'armée chinoise en tant que telle,
bon là euh euh les gard c'est pas
l'armée, la la la l'armée chinoise, la
dernière fois qu' sor frontières,
c'était dans cette guerre courte mais
assez sanglante contre le Vietnam qui
s'est déroulé en 1979.
Donc vous voyez que on accuse souvent la
Chine d'être agressive mais si vous
regardez les États-Unis qui se
considèrent comme un grand pays
pacifique, ils sont en garde tout le
temps. Alors que dans l'armée chinoise,
le plus haut gradé de l'armée chinoise
qui est en train de prendre sa retraite
n'a en réalité jamais euh connu de
guerre pratiquement. C'est pour ça que
la Chine envoie des Chinois s'aguérir au
combat en Ukraine
? Bon, alors là, c'est c'est
effectivement une question un petit peu
litigieuse parce que on a trouvé deux ou
trois Chinois
perdu. Oui. Enfin bon,
donc c'était des gens qui étaient
attirés par la solde que offrait l'armée
russe apparemment. Mais je pense que si
vraiment la Chine voulait aider la
Russie militairement, ce sont pas ces
deux ou trois soldats perdu qu'elle
aurait envoyé. Euh je pense que elle a
des moyens qui sont quand même plus
efficaces. Vous parlez de la Russie,
est-ce que les Russes ont peur des
Chinois par rapport à ce qu'il y a de
l'autre côté du fleuve amour qui est en
train de se faire coloniser bonant
malant par les Chinois ?
Alors, c'est une excellente question
parce que tout le monde parle
effectivement de l'amitié éternelle
entre les Russes et les Chinois. Euh je
n'ai jamais été convaincu par cette idée
et en réalité historiquement euh donc il
y a eu des moments actuellement par
exemple où pour des raisons euh
géopolitiques ou géostratégique la
Russie et la Chine sont très proches.
Bon mais euh historiquement il n'y a
jamais eu de d'amour véritablement enfin
au sens propre entre les deux peuples en
changer.
[Musique]
Je je n'en suis pas sûr parce que en
fait quand on regarde un peu la quand on
étudier la mon enfin d'abord je voudrais
faire un rappel
historique. Vous savez que au 19e siècle
la Chine a été vaincue par tout un
ensemble de nations
occidentales donc qui ont créé ce qu'on
appelle les traités inégaux. Bon et on a
le sentiment que finalement ces traités
négau euh ont eu une fin avec la
rétrocession de Hong Kong en
1937. Mais c'est faux parce que vous
avez encore une partie extrêmement
importante du théâtre chinois qui a été
occupée par la nation étrangère qui l'a
jamais rendu. C'est la Russie qui a
occupé toute une partie de la Sibérie du
de l'est avec comme ville principale
Vladock. Varoc était une ville chinoise,
c'était pas une ville en russe du tout.
Donc en fait, les Russes n'ont jamais
rendu et on on calcule que il a à peu
près encore 2 millions de kilomètres
carrés de
territoire anciennement chinois,
toujours s'occupe. C'était en quelle
année le territoire chinois en Sibérie
qui était ça s'est fait en plusieurs
vagues donc mais c'est en en gros au
cours du 19e siècle et cette occupation
et cette occupation par les Russes a été
entérinée par le traité d'amitié que la
Chine et la Russie ont signé. Donc
maintenant c'est de l'histoire c'est
fini. La Chine ne revendique plus Vadiv
Vasok par exemple. Mais si vous regardez
la carte, vous vous rendez compte que
toutes les provinces du nord-est euh de
la Chine donc la particularité de ne pas
avoir accès sur la mer parce que elles
sont au nord bloquées par la Sibérie. Et
puis vous avez cette étroite langue de
terre qui relie la Sibérie à la Corée du
Nord qui fait que toutes ces provinces
du Nordest donc sont coupées de l'accès
à la mer.
Revenons à la question initiale. Quand
je vois la Chine développer l'équivalent
d'une marine française par an, quand je
vois les avancé technologique de l'armée
chinoise en terme de drone, quand je
vois les routes de la soie pour avoir un
plan B au cas où la sécurisation du
collier de perle par les troupes
américaines, quand je vois euh
Sijingping faire des revendications de
la réunification de Taiwan, quand je
vois la Chine racheter des ports à
gauche et à droite en
Europe. Est-ce que ce n'est pas un
rouleau
compresseur qui se met en marche pour
récupérer une hégémonie planétaire
?
Alors, vous faites un amalgame de
beaucoup d'idées qui sont différentes
donc et il faut il faut faire un peu le
tri. Bon, je vais commencer par tawan.
Alors, amalgame, vous êtes bijoutier et
vous triez mes idées. Je vous écoute.
Bon, ben j'aurais commencé par Tawan
parce que ça me paraît extrêmement
important. Euh quand je suis en France
et quand je parle avec les amis, ils
font souvent la comparaison très
tentante de dire Ukraine, Tawen, Russie,
Chine. Bon, en réalité, je veux insister
sur le fait que la situation est quand
même complètement différente parce que
l'Ukraine est un pays indépendant qui
est reconnu par tous les pays des
Nations- Unies.
Et quand la Russie attaque l'Ukraine, la
Russie attaque un pays indépendant qui
est différent de la Russie, même si
historiquement ils avaient des liens.
Tandis que dans le cas de Tao et de la
Chine, donc il faut bien constater que
la plus grande la plus grande majorité
des pays au monde reconnaissent cette
phrase extrêmement importante qui a été
négociée pendant 3 jours et 3 nuits par
Henrique Singer avec Twendler en 1972.
et que tous les pays qui en tout cas ont
des relations diplomatiques la Chine
reconnaisse qui est il n'y a qu'une
seule Chine et on en a fait partie.
C'est-à-dire que la plupart des nations
monde à part une poignée de petits
états, reconnaissent que il n'y a qu'une
seule Chine et Tawan fait partie de
cette Chine. Donc si vous voulez sur le
plan ne serait-ce que du droit
international, la situation de l'Ukraine
par rapport à la Russie est quand même
extrêmement différente de la situation
de Tawan avec la Chine. Donc c'est c'est
un des éléments sur lesquels vous
insistez amis font quoi de la vie pour
avoir ce type de point de vue ?
Mes amis, parl de ça. Alors le justement
c'est c'est ça qui me paraît extrêmement
chinois français. Non, je parle des amis
français donc mes amis chinois eux
connaissent bien cette situation. Mais
justement on est dans une situation qui
est assez complexe parce que la plupart
de mes amis français disent "Mais bon en
fait on comprend que il y a une
situation un peu compliquée mais
pourquoi ne pas garder le statut court
?" Bon, donc c'est c'est ce que la
plupart de mes amis français souhaitent
en disant bah on est dans une situation
qui n'est pas si mauvaise que cela. Bon,
le le problème du statut quo leur
réponge et est que euh c'est une
situation qui n'est pas
stable. Lorsqu'on fait des études de
physique en classe de seconde, on
apprend qu'un pendule a deux positions
d'équilibre.
une position d'équilibre, vous avez la
boule qui est en bas et vous avez une
position d'équilibre théorique où la
boule est en haut, sauf que la position
d'équilibre où la boule est en haut est
instable. C'est un peu le problème du
statut court. C'est-à-dire que à partir
du moment où vous avez le statut court,
ça signifie que vous pouvez aussi bien
basculer vers la réunification
unification du territoire avec la la
Chine continentale comme vous pouvez
basculer vers l'indépendance. Donc c'est
une situation qui est instable et c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'est une
situation qui ne peut pas être acceptée
par la Chine. Quand quand vous
voyez Donald Trump qui entre les lignes
désigne son réel ennemi qui est la Chine
avec la course à l'intelligence
artificielle dopée de par de l'énergie à
foison.
Nous avons
étudié les plans énergétiques chinois,
leur stratégie énergétique. Nous
étudions les stratégies énergétiques
américaines et leur course à
l'intelligence
artificielle. Est-ce que le nouveau dieu
de l'intelligence artificielle sera soit
américain, soit chinois
? Vous en pensez quoi vous qui est qui
êtes à la fois avec un pied en France et
à Marseille et un pied en Chine ? Vous
avez vécu là-bas 3 7 ans ? Plus que ça,
ça fait plus de 20 ans que je suis en
Chine. Vous êtes marié avec une chinoise
architecte ? Je suis marié avec une
chinoise architecte née à Londres.
Donc vous imaginez la difficulté, nous
vivons d'endre de couple la guerre de
100 ans tous les jours avec la perfid
d'Albion. Voilà. Absolument. Et ça ça
fait 47 ans que ça dure. Donc vous
utilisez une intelligence artificielle ?
Alors euh nous on on utilise
l'intelligence artificielle enfin quand
on vit en Chine, on se rend compte qu'on
utilise de plus en plus effectivement
l'intelligence artificielle et euh on
l'utilise dans la vie de tous les jours.
Donc ça c'est aussi un phénomène que je
constate avec stupeur, c'est que le
Covid a eu une
conséquence
extrêmement néfaste et qui est que les
étrangers ou les
Français vont beaucoup moins en
Chine après les années Covid.
Et le résultat est que beaucoup
d'étrangers, d'Européens ou d'Américains
ont une vision de la Chine qui qui date
de pas très longtemps mais des années
2020 ou des années antérieures 2020,
donc 5 ans auparavant. et on n' pas idée
de la façon dont la Chine a pu évoluer
pendant 5 années. Et les souvenirs que
beaucoup de mes amis ont de la Chine
sont en réalité souvenirs qui sont
obsolètes maintenant.
Donc pour revenir à la question initiale
sur Trump, la course à l'intelligence
artificielle, la Chine la course à
l'intelligence artificielle, les plans
énergétiques, vous percevez ça comment ?
Je perçois cela. Bon, comme vous le
dites, donc je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec votre analyse et avec le fait que
en effet les deux pays enfin que ce soit
Trump ou que ce soit sitting Ping pour
prendre ces deux personnages comme
symbole sont convaincus que l'avenir
appartient à celui qui maîtrisera
effectivement l'intelligence
artificielle. Donc la première réaction
que j'ai qui est une réaction je dirais
française, c'est que il est quand même
extrêmement important de pouvoir réguler
un petit peu cette course parce que
l'intelligence artificielle c'est à la
fois un instrument qui est
extraordinairement puissant mais ça peut
être aussi un danger. Et si on ne
maîtrise
pas cette intelligence
artificielle, est-ce qu'on ne court pas
à la perte de l'humanité ? C'est une
question qu'on peut à mon avis
légitimement se poser. Je je je ne suis
pas suffisamment versé dans cette
question pour pouvoir apporter une
réponse, mais simplement comme
observateur extérieur, je me pose quand
même la question et je pense que il va
falloir quand même se se pencher
là-dessus et je constate que il y a un
certain nombre de gens qui militent pour
que Américains et Chinois se mettent
d'accord pour dicter un peu des
règles. ce qui me paraît quand même
difficile, surtout quand on connaît le
caractère de Trump pour qui les règles
ne sont pas vraiment la préoccupation
essentielle.
Si je vous dis intelligence artificielle
et crédit social, caméra de
vidéosurveillance dans les
rues, comment vous vous analysez ça en
tant que français avec un pied en Chine
? Alors écoute, vous avez la double
double nationalité ou pas ? Non non, je
suis une nationalité française. On on
peut pas avoir de double nationalité en
Chine. C'estàd ou bien on est chinois ou
bien on a une autre nationalité mais on
ne peut pas avoir de de double
nationalité. Écoutez, votre votre
question est très intéressante et je
vais vous dire de façon très simple
comment les choses se passent. Euh en
particulier quand euh j'ai des amis
français qui arrivent en Chine, ils sont
à priori horrifiés. Quand vous dites, la
question qu'il pose et celle que vous
posez, enfin c'est c'est extraordinaire.
On à tous les carrefours, à tous les
coins de rue, on a des caméras donc euh
on a aucune liberté. Donc euh vous savez
combien la liberté est importante pour
un français. Bon, donc c'est sa première
réaction. Mais au fur et à mesure que le
temps s'écoule quand il reste sur un
long en Chine, il s'y habitue et se rend
compte que finalement le fait d'être
surveillé sans cesse n'impacte pas
véritablement sa vie quotidienne et en
revanche ça apporte un certain nombre
d'avantages considérables. J'ai j'ai un
ami par exemple euh français qui euh a
perdu euh son portefeuille. il a oublié
son portefeuille dans le panier de son
vélo. C'est que en Chine, vous avez
beaucoup de vélos en libre à service
donc et euh c'est excellent pratique.
Donc il avait oublié dans et il s'en est
souvenu euh 3 ou 4 ans après. Donc il
est allé courir au poste de police. Bon
voilà, j'ai perdu mon mon portefeuille
avec mon passeport dedans. Donc il était
évidemment très stressé. J'ai dit bon
écoutez calmez-vous. Ils ont regardé sur
les caméras, ils ont trouvé donc ce qui
était arrivé à ce à ce portefeuille. Bon
donc et 3h après, il avait récupéré le
portefeuille. C'est une chose
inimaginable à Paris.
Donc si vous voulez enf je je ne
justifie pas, je je fais que décrire une
situation et je constate que euh la
plupart des Français, je parle des
Français qui vivent en Chine donc et que
je fréquente se sont habitués à cette
surveillance et finalement ça ne gêne
pas plus que ça. Vous connaissez le
vieil
adage pardon ? Vous connaissez le vieil
adage ? Ceux prêt à sacrifier un peu de
leur liberté pour plus de sécurité ne
méritent ni l'un ni l'autre. Bon,
revenons, revenons à nos moutons. On se
on on va repartir un peu historiquement
parlant. Il y a 25 ans, la Chine, ça
ressemblait à quoi ? Un quart de siècle.
Il y a euh 25 ans, la nouvelle Chine,
pardon, la nouvelle Chine, à 25 ans, la
Chine, alors si on prend une image
simple qui est le PIB, par exemple, le
PIB de la Chine était inférieur à celui
de la France ou à celui de la
Grande-Bretagne. Bon et euh maintenant
c'est devenu cinq fois le PIB de ces de
ces pays. C'est pas arrivé par magie.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me parler des
pionniers, les enfants pionniers avec le
foulard rouge ?
Euh, écoutez ça euh ça a disparu. Enfin,
vous parlez des gardes rouges. Je vous
parle des des enfants les meilleurs à
l'école avec des parents qui étaient au
parti certes, mais des enfants avec un
un foulard rouge autour du cou et qui
étaient euh des bêtes à concours, je
dirais les meilleurs à l'école, les
meilleurs partout. Qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
devenus ces enfants
? Est-ce qu'ils sont partis Est-ce
qu'ils font partie maintenant de l'élite
du parti communiste chinois
? J'allais vous dire vous vous vous
décrivez un petit peu mon enfance. Si
vous permettez, je reviens sur mon
enfance marseillaise. Bon, à l'époque,
j'étais, comme je disais, dans une
famille chinoise et il y avait très peu
de familles chinoises. Notre famille
était l'une des quelques-unes habitant à
Marseille.
Et j'ai bien sûr été élevé par ma par ma
mère. Et ma mère m'a toujours inculquer
cette notion en disant "Nous sommes en
France et nous sommes chinois. Donc nous
sommes pas tout à fait comme les autres
Français. Si dans l'avenir tu veux
pouvoir t'en sortir, il faut que tu sois
deux fois meilleur que le français avec
qui je ser en confiance sinon tu n'en
sortiras pas."
Donc j'avais cette pression de ma mère
qui a exigé que je sois premier à
l'école. J'ai toujours été premier à
l'école, enfin en tout cas dans l'école
primaire, l'école secondaire, mais ma
mère a exigé que je sois premier dans
toutes les
discipline et je me trouvais face à
cette injustice que je trouvais quand
même extrêmement grave qui était que
lorsque je rapportais mon carnet
scolaire à la maison, je me faisais
réprimander si j'étais pas pré dans une
des disciplines. Je disais à mes
parents, mais enfin mais si n'importe
lequel de mes camarades rapport ce
carnet à ses parents mais il serait
fêté. comme on peut pas l'imaginer et
moi je me fais gronder parce que je ne
suis pas premier dans une des
disciplines. Donc je je veux simplement
dire que il il y a cette pression
continue que la famille exerce
effectivement sur les sur les enfants.
Je je je vais vous dire comment je suis
entré à l'école
polytechnique. Mon père est arrivé en
France 1937. Pour quelle raison ? Alors
il avait une mission qui lui a été
donnée par le gouvernement chinois. Je
vais pas m'étendre là-dessus parce que
sinon ce serait trop compliqué. Mais
enfin, il était venu en disant il était
jeune homme, il avait fini ses études et
il est arrivé en en France en 197. 1937
une date très importante parce que on
parlait tout à l'heure donc des traités
inégaux et du du siècle
donc de la honte de Oui, c'est ça. de
donc du du siècle de la honte des des
Chinois. 1937 c'était le c'était
vraiment le point le plus bas parce que
1937 c'est l'année où le Japon est venu
envahir la Chine. Bon donc on ne pouvait
pas tomber plus bas toutes les
satrocités.
Bon donc on savait pas encore puisque
c'est c'était le début mais enfin bon.
Donc euh et mon père est arrivé en
France et il était éperduation sur la
France.
dit "Mais comment se fait-il que la
France soit aussi en avance alors que la
Chine est aussi en retard ?" Alors, il a
essayé d'analyser un peu la situation et
dit "Bon, les Français sont
intelligents, enfin les chemins sont pas
bêtes, les Français sont travailleurs
mais bon l'impression qu'il avait était
que Chinois était encore plus
travailleur que que les Français à
l'époque déjà."
Et finalement, il est arrivé assez
rapidement conclusion, il dit "Mais en
fait c'est parce que la Chine depuis des
siècles et des siècles a raté un virage
qui est le virage de la science et de la
technologie." Alors il s'est enseigné
dit "Quelle est la meilleure école où on
puisse apprendre la science et la
technologie en France sur le répondu
l'école polytechnique ?" Alors il est
allé frapper à la porte de l'école
est-ce que je peux venir étudier ? Il
s'est rendu compte que c'était pas
possible formation mathématique en fait
il avait pas tout ce qu'il fallait et il
était un peu trop âgé aussi. Et alors,
il s'est juré, il dit "Bon, moi je ne
peux pas entrer l'école polytechnique
mais mon fils entra à l'école
polytechnique et mon fils était moi." À
l'époque, mon père non seulement euh
n'était pas enfin n'avait pas d'enfants,
mais était même pas marié. Autrement
dit, j'étais programmé pour entrer à
l'école polytechnique avant même ma
naissance. Bon, donc il a bien fallu que
je respecte la volonté de mon père et
c'est ma mère qui m'a donné les moyens
effectivement de le faire par la par la
pression. Donc cette pression que moi
j'ai connu enfant euh chinois
marseillais, ben cette pression que des
millions d'enfants connaissent en Chine
de nos jours et et le résultat est un
résultat qui euh du point de vue
français est
effrayant. Euh pourquoi ? Parce que vous
savez, il y a il y a une notion
actuellement euh qui émerge au niveau de
l'éducation, c'est la la notion de stem.
Est-ce que vous voyez de quoi je parle ?
STM ? Ben, c'est une notion comme
toujours initiée par les Américains.
STEM, ça signifie science, technology,
engineering,
mathématics. C'est-à-dire que il y a une
statistique qui maintenant euh
rassemble ces quatre disciplines. On
regarde quel quels sont les diplômés et
en particulier en fait des statistiques
sur le nombre de diplômés de STEM.
Et bien je veux dire le résultat actuel.
Vous prenez le nombre de diplômés de
STEM aux
États-Unis, vous rajoutez le nombre
diplomés de STEM au Japon, vous rajoutez
l'Allemagne, vous rajoutez la France,
vous avez un total, vous multipliez ce
total par deux et vous avez le nombre de
STEM en Chine. Donc vous vous voyez,
vous avez enfin pour vous donner des
chiffres enfin euh concrets, vous avez
union et demi d'ingénieurs qui sont
formés chaque année en Chine. vous avez
50000 en France et 200000 aux
États-Unis.
Donc vous vous avez une masse, une
quantité, c'est résultat de cette
pression qui fait que bon vous avez
effectivement en terme de quantité une
situation où la Chine est pour l'instant
imbattable et vous savez qu' le seul
pays qui éventuellement pourrait
dépasser la Chine, c'est
l'Inde. L'Inde a
12500 ingénieurs formés chaque
année. Je reviens à ma question sur les
pionniers. Vous avez répondu
partiellement.
Quand la Chine nouvelle a été
créée et que la Chine s'est mis au
travail, je voudrais que vous décriviez
la substantielle
moelle du chinois patriotique
patriote. Qu'est-ce qui le guide ? et
son amour de la Chine, son amour de la
patrie, son amour de sa mère ou de sa
grand-mère, de ses ancêtres, c'est un
sentiment de fierté, de vengeance.
Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que la substantielle
moelle d'un chinois qui va être
travailleur travailleur travailleur pour
être premier premier premier premier
partout ?
Alors, je vais vous étonner.
Mais le
patriotisme est une notion relativement
nouvelle en Chine. L'amour de la Chine
n'est pas du tout quelque chose
d'ancien. Le le Chinois
vitriques. Il y a d'abord sa famille, il
y a son village, il y a sa région, il y
a sa province. Bon et la notion de Chine
en elle-même donc et l'amour de la Chine
est quelque chose de relativement récent
de la génération des pionniers.
euh de cet end si je peux appeler ça
comme ça. Alors même ainsi, vous savez
la la Chine donc a une population
importante puisquon est 1AR 400
millions et elle deviennent 30
provinces.
C'est-à-dire que les grandes provinces
chinoises font 100 millions d'habitants.
Euh si une province si une grande
province chinoise était était un pays en
Europe, ce serait le plus grand pays
européen enfin certaines de ces
provinces. Donc en fait euh et et en
plus les Chinois sont sont très
différents les uns des autres.
On vous raconte la Chine est un pays
composé de 56 ethnies dans lesquelles il
a une etnie majoritaire qui est l'han
qui fait 94 % de la population. C'est ce
qu'on vous apprend lorsque vous
débarquez de l'avion et que vous lisez
un premier princectus sur la Chine. Sauf
que on vous explique pas que les reines
sont extrêmement diversifiées. Les les
cantonnés sont des reines, les gens du
chon sont du
renang sont des reines, les péquinois
sont des reines aussi mais en fait ils
ne parlent pas la même langue. Donc ils
n'ont pas les mêmes habitudes
alimentaires. Donc ils n'ont pas la même
taille, ils ne se ressemblent pas. Donc
ils n'ont pas les mêmes coutumes. Donc
ce sont en réalité des communautés qui
sont extrêmement extrêmement
diversifiées. La seule chose qui est
réunie, c'est l'écriture. L'écriture est
la même partout en Chine. Mais qu'est-ce
que je veux dire par là ? Je veux dire
par là que l'idée de de l'amour de la
Chine, du patrime est une idée encore
une fois relativement nouvelle parce que
la notion même de Chine est une notion
qui est relativement
nouvelle pour les Chinois. C'est quoi
nouvelle ? C'est 25 ans et les
pionniers.
C'est la nouvelle Chine. Alors euh je je
je dirais pour simplifier que on peut
faire remonter par signification quand
même un peu plus tôt. Moi moi je ferai
remonter au fondateur de la République
de Chine Soyatsen donc de la première
République chinoise en 1911 quoi si vous
voulez. Bon et euh en fait euh il y a un
personnage qui actuellement est en train
de jouer un rôle extrêmement important
pour
augmenter l'amour des Chinois pour la
Chine. Vous savez qui c'est ? Quel est
ce héros ? C'est Donald Trump.
Parce que Donald Trump en attaquant les
Chinois en tant que tel est en train de
créer est en train de renforcer un
sentiment national extrêmement
important. Attends ce qui se passe en
Russie d'ailleurs. Ah je je connais mal
la Russie donc mais vous avez été sur la
plastan ? Si, j'ai été sur la place. Ah
mais bien sûr. Oui. Vous avez fait une
photo de la placeamun avec vous dessus ?
Euh écoutez je Est-ce que le portrait
était à votre gauche ou à votre droite à
fond ?
Écoutez, je je ne suis pas un je ne suis
pas un très grand amateur de photos donc
euh je ne pense pas avoir une photo de
boin sur la sur la place de vous lire
avec le portrait de Mao par par rapport
derrière c'est c'est pas très facile à
prendre. Vous savez que
actuellement sur la la la place est très
grande. Je vais poser une colle entre la
place à Concord la place. Quelle est la
plus grande ?
Plus grande de combien de fois ? Si mes
souvenirs sont bons, je dirais de 18
fois. Ah non non non, vous exagérez. La
place fait à peu près 4 à c fois la
place à Concorde. Enfin bon, donc mais
très souvent les gens se posent des
questions parce que on se rend pas
compte. Donc et vous avez des gens qui
vous disent que la place congorde est
plus grande que la place. Bon
donc euh c'est c'est quand même
extrêmement grand quoi. Revenons à ce
sentiment
patriotique. On entend nous souvent les
Européens le loup
guerrier. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous
l'expliquer
? Le en fait le loup guerrier est un peu
un avatar. Vous savez, c'est un film en
fait.
C'est un film et euh c'est
une
euh création relativement
récente euh et qui euh en fait reprend
une idée qui a été développée euh pas
mal d'années
auparavant par un autre personnage qui
est euh resté très célèbre dans
l'inconscient des chinois. C'est Bruce
Lee. Vous vous rappelez qui était Bruce
Lee ? Un petit peu quand même. Be Water
my friend. Exactement. Bon très bien.
C'est une c extrêmement important. Mais
Bruce Lee est extrêmement important
parce que Bruce Lee a été le premier
acteur chinois. Donc Brue était
américain d'ailleurs. Oui. Enfin euh je
sais pas s'il a pris nationalité.
effectivement, il a fait une carrière
aux États-Unis, mais enfin à l'origine,
c'était quand même un acteur de Hong
Kong et mais surtout c'est le premier
acteur qui a commencé à faire des films
patriotiques véritablement dans lesquels
on voyait les Chinois être fiers d'être
Chinois. Donc bon, Bruce Lee vous savez,
est mort très tôt. Donc Bruce Lee
c'était les années 70. Bon et depuis
donc on est passé un peu à autre chose
jusqu'à une époque relativement récente
où vous avez le signe machinois qui a
ressorti donc cette série. Il y en a eu
il y a eu deux films, je crois qu'
s'appelait les Loup Guerriers
effectivement où on voit les les les
Chinois un petit peu comme Rambo, enfin
un petit peu comme les les films de
guerre américain et non pas être des
victimes mais être véritablement des
héros au sens américain du
terme. Donc ensuite, on a utilisé cette
expression pour qualifier un certain
nombre de de diplomates parce que l'idée
en effet était un peu la même, c'est de
dire que il ne fallait pas que la Chine
continue à
suivre la le mot d'ordre qui avait été
donné, vous savez,
paring qui avait dit que il faut
cultiver ses forces et rester à l'écart
de la lumière. Donc c'était ça. Alors
euh on dit souvent que City Ping donc
n'a pas respecté ce mode de Ting. Bon en
fait c'est pas tout à fait ça. Ce qui se
passe c'est que Tin avait donné cette ce
conseil à son époque. À l'époque la
Chine encore une fois était beaucoup
plus faible qu'elle ne l'it. Quandoping
a pris les reines de la Chine, comme je
vous le disais, la la Chine avait un PIB
qui était très inférieur à celui de la
France, la Grande-Bretagne, l'Allemagne,
enfin de tous les la plupart des pays
occidentaux. Donc il n'avait pas la
possibilité effectivement de montrer sa
force. Euh City Pin estime que on est
passé à une autre étape où on a plus
besoin peut-être de rester autant dans
l'obscurité. D'où cette notion de de
loup guerrier ? C'est resté dans
l'obscurité ou
c'est continué à baisser la tête
?
Euh alors le concept de Ting n'était pas
de baisser la
tête. Donc TP n'a jamais voulu baisser
la tête
devant qui que soit.
Vous savez que tu n'approches plus façon
sunzu, c'est-à-dire prétendre d'être
faible pendant qu'on se renforce.
Euh ce n'est alors euh c'est je pense un
tout petit peu
différent euh mais l'inspiration est la
même. C'est non pas aller jusqu'à
prétendre être faible mais c'est cacher
sa force ou cacher le fait qu'on est en
train de se
renforcer. Et effectivement c'est une
stratégie que l'on voit partout. Je je
donne un exemple dans un secteur de
France qui est le secteur
l'automobile. Moi, moi j'ai été très
frappé par le fait que j'ai pas mal
d'amis qui travaillent dans de
l'automobile, des Français, des
Américains, des des
Allemands et
qui donc sont allés en Chine pour
développer l'industrie automobile
chinoise et
qui finalement constatait que les
Chinois avaient beaucoup de mal à
rattraper le retard des occidentaux dans
l'automobile sur les moteurs thermiques.
Justement, c'est bien là le problème. Il
ils ne se sont pas rendus compte que en
fait les Chinois ne cherchaient pas à
rattraper l'Allemagne ou la
Grande-Bretagne ou le Japon sur les
véhicules thermiques. La Chine a fait
l'impasse là-dessus parce que il
constatait qu'il y avait pas un grand
intérêt et la Chine a passé des années
et des années à développer le véhicule
électrique. Ce qui fait que
lorsque la technologie chinoise des
véhicules électriques est
apparue donc au monde entier, le monde
entien était surpris parce que ils
avaient complètement raté le fait que
les Chinois travaillaient depuis très
très longtemps là-dessus et que alors
c'est une technique que qui porte un
nom. Les Américains appellent ça le lip
frog, le le saut de grenouille.
C'est-à-dire que on passe d'une
technologie à une autre par un saut de
grenouille et on courtcircuite
finalement toutes les technologies
intermédiaires. La la la Chine a fait ça
de façon
systématique. Euh elle a fait ça fait
d'autres systématiquement bah pour les
télécommunications. Moi je
rappelle elle a fait du renseignement,
elle a copié des technologies, elle a
aspiré des technologies chez les
concurrents. Paraît-il que le mot copier
est différent en chinois dans la
symbolique que nous nous pouvons avoir ?
Alors c'est même plus que ça c'est que
c'est le même mot le mot sue en chinois
signifie à la fois apprendre et copier.
C'est le même mot qui signifie apprendre
et copier.
Mais je vous signale que c'est la même
chose en Europe. Si vous prenez les
grands peintres, la Renaissance, les
Raphaël, les Mquing et autres, ils ont
passé le province de Livier à copier les
maîtres et c'est qu'ensuite ce qu'ils
sont mis à créer qu's ont créé les chef
d'œuvres que nous connaissons. Vous
connaissez l'histoire avec le verre de
la soie verre à
soi. Racontez cette histoire à notre
audience. Le le l'histoire de faire soi
euh les Européens ont piqué. Oui, donc
avec les moines qui sont qui sont
revenues de de de Chine avec les avec
les œufs de Verasso dans les pomo de
l'arcane al des des pèlerins. alors
effectivement vous avez raison de de
rappeler cette histoire parce que quand
les Européens ou les Américains accusent
les Chinois d'avoir copié les
technologies européennes pour se
développer, les Chinois leur étorquent
que ce sont quand même les Européens qui
les premiers ont piqué la technologie de
de des verres à sois, pas technologie
même les œufs des ver à sois donc pour
les apporter en Europe. les Chinois ont
bien appris.
Il ils ont fait ils ont fait
effectivement la ils ont fait
effectivement la même chose. Donc ils
ont au départ euh commencé
par copier
par prendre les technologies par enfin
bon ils ont fait ce qu'il pouvaient pour
gagner du temps avant de développer leur
propre technologie.
Qu'est-ce que veut la Chine ? Elle veut
récupérer son statut qu'on lui a volé,
redevenir la première puissance mondiale
d'une façon écrasante pour les 1000
prochaines
années. La Chine n'a jamais été ce que
vous appelez une première puissance
mondiale. Quand même un
peu. La la pour la Chine la Chine avait
une notion où vous savez la Chine ne
s'est jamais intéressée euh à à
l'extérieur. Il y avait le monde chinois
et et le reste de ne pas tellement. Vous
connaissez l'histoire de
l'omalro d' le navigateur, le stratège
des mers. Alors mais mais Chre c'est
très intéressant. Chre est allé faire
sep voyages en Chine à partir de 1420.
Moi, j'ai été, comme je vous le disais,
élevé euh donc à la française dans les
écoles françaises et on m'a
appris que l'institutrice m'avait appris
que si Christophe Colomb a pu découvrir
l'Amérique 1492, c'était grâce à
plusieurs inventions. Il y avait la
boussole donc et il y avait la
caravelle. La caravel qui est un év
géant, vous vous rendez compte la
caravel faisait 30 la Santa Maria de
Christophe Colomb faisait 30 m de long.
Donc pendant très longtemps, je suis
resté dans cette idée que la découvre de
l'Amérique a été rendue possible par les
inventions, la boussole et la caravane.
Je me suis rendu compte ensuite que
d'une part la boussole comme vous le
savez avait inventée par les Chinois et
que d'autre part quand Jun est aller
faire
donc ses ses croisières pour aller
jusque au sud de l'Afrique la Jun amiral
Chun faisait 100 m de long était
beaucoup plus important plus grande que
la Santa Mariaade de de Rov Colon et
pourtant a fait sep voyages
jusqu'à la corne de l'Afrique et Chun
n'a jamais établi la moindre colonie. Il
n'a jamais conquis le moindre territoire
que ce soit en Asie Sud-Est ou que ce
soit en Afrique. Et vous savez ce qui
s'est passé ensuite, c'est que quand il
est rentré, donc il était plus ou moins
en dis grâce et l'empereur Ming à
l'époque avait interdit de construire
des navires dont le coût était
extrêmement important et qui ne servait
à rien. Donc vous voyez la différence de
mentalité entre les espagnols qui à
l'époque grâce à une technologie
innovante en Europe les sont allés
conquérir toute l'Amérique. Enfin vous
connaissez l'histoire des grandes
explorations et des grandes conquêtes.
Et les Chinois et et les Chinois qui
auparavant avaient cette technologie une
technologie même supérieure n'ont
absolument pas eu envie de conquire le
monde. Donc c'est c'est là ce que je
veux dire, c'est en terme de mentalité,
les les Chinois n'ont jamais été
intéressés par dominer le monde. Mais ce
que les Chinois ne supporte pas, c'est
qu'on leur dicte effectivement un mode
de vie, qu'on leur dicte donc des règles
à suivre. Et le comble de l'humiliation,
vous savez, qui a été effectivement
décrit par Bruce Lee, revient à Bruce
Lee dans ce film où l'on voit un moment
dans un jardin public de Shanghï cette
pancarte interdit aux chiens et aux
chinois. Ça les cheveux me supportent
pas. Il y a du racisme en Chine.
Est-ce que pardon ? Est-ce qu'il y a du
racisme en Chine ?
Vousz la vérité.
Vous êtes là pour pousser un cady ?
Oui, il y a du racisme en Chine. En
quelle forme
?
Euh ça prend la forme que
euh les gens considèrent que les autres
sont différents. Bon donc ils vont pas
leur euh chercher des des des ennu
nécessairement. Mais
effectivement il n'y a peut-être
pas euh enfin il n'y a pas en tout cas
cette notion très européenne, cette
notion très universelle d'amour
universel si vous voulez.
Euh la c'est c'est c'est très
intéressant le cette question d'amour
universel, cette question d'égalité
entre les
hommes. C'est une notion très culturelle
que moi je fais remonter au
christianisme. C'est c'est c'est toute
la la je veux dire la grandeur du
christianisme, la difficulté
christianisme d'avoir inventé cette
notion d'égalité entre les hommes et
cette notion d'amour universel. Vous
vous savez
que il y a un philosophe
chinois qui lui aussi à peu près à la
même époque enfin la grande époque de
Confus enfin de de enfin de cette époque
au 4e 5e siècle avant Jésus-Christ et
qui avait développé cette notion d'amour
universel. Ce philosophe s'appelait
Moz et ce philosophe a été complètement
oublié. C'estàdire, il était à l'époque
rival de Confessus mais sa philosophie a
été complètement oubliée jusque au
moment où elle a été redécouverte par
les jésuites qui étaient ravis de
trouver qu'il y avait un ancien
philosophe chinois qui avait aussi conçu
cette notion d'amour universel qui leur
permettait évidemment d'erre le
christianisme. Donc ce qui me paraît
extrêmement
intéressant, c'est que vous avez en
Chine des philosophes qui avaient eu
cette même idée d'abord universel mais
ça n'a pas pris. Et à l'inverse, vous
avez dans la Grèce antique donc le grand
philosophe la Grèce antique c'est
Socrate et Platon. Bon mais vous avez un
philosophe donc grec qui comme les
Chinois s'intéressaient moins à la
vérité qu'au changement. Vous savez,
c'est ce philosophe qui a dit "On se
baigne jamais deux fois dans la même
rivière." Vous rappelez comment il
s'appelle ? Il s'appelait Hérclite.
Héraclite. Héraclite. Héraclite est un
très grand philosophe qui à l'époque
était aussi rival de Platon de tous ces
philosophes. Sauf que Hclit a développé
faisait on lui a donné un surnom, on
l'appelait Héraclit l'obscur parce que
sa philosophie était incompréhensible
pour les Grecs. Donc c'est quelqu'un qui
a dévelé une philosophie qui était
beaucoup plus proche de la pensée
chinoise mais qui a été comme nom oublié
qui a été laissé tomber par les Grecs.
Les Grecs ont choisi Platon, les Chinois
ont choisi Confucius alors qu'ils
avaient le choix d'autres penseurs. Donc
au mo pour les Chinois, Héraclit pour
les Grecs. Mais vous avez une espèce de
génie du peuple qui a fait que ils ont
choisi leur propre philosophe.
On va repartir sur le sujet guerre
économique. Faut-il se méfier de la
Chine ou avoir peur de la Chine
? À quoi ça ressemble le soft power
chinois en 2025 ? Question internet.
À quoi ressemble ? Pardon le soft power.
Oui.
Ah très bonne
question de Gaë. Ouais très bonne
question et ma réponse de dire que c'est
une des faiblesses de la Chine. La la
Chine n'a pas su développer son soft
power.
Donc la la la Chine et et je me
l'aperçois
maintenant la la Chine est très mal vue
par les pays étrangers y compris la
France où je suis et et quand je revois
mes amis français ils
ont mais mes mais mes mes amis français
con depuis très longtemps donc avait il
y a il y a 10 ans, il y a il y a 20 ans
euh une très grande intérêt et euh pour
la Chine et et je constate à mon
désespoir qu'ils l'ont perdu. Donc la la
Chine a un réel besoin de de développer
son son soft power
qui est, je dois le le reconnaître
inférieur au soft port américain, en
tout cas jusqu'à l'époque de monsieur
Trump. Maintenant, monsieur Trump est en
train de réaliser un exploit. Il est en
train de de faire éclater le soft power
américain. Alors, peut-être que grâce à
ça, les Chinois vont pouvoir reprendre,
rattraper un peu le retard. C'est quoi
le hard power de la Chine ? Le ch c'est
le
nombre je vous ai donné tout à l'heure
les ingénieurs. C'est nombre mais mais
de tout que soit les ingénieurs, que ce
soit la euh que ce soit le l'industrie,
que ce soit tout en terme de nombre,
vous ne pouvez pas dépasser la Chine.
Comment les Chinois font du
renseignement ? Écoutez, alors ça je ça
je ne sais pas, ça c'est c'est pas ma
c'est pas ma spécialité. Alors, on dit
toujours que les Français, les
Américains, les Européens quand ils vont
faire du renseignement, ils envoient un
gars à la plage avec un saut pour
ramener un saut de sable. Imaginez-vous,
le sable, c'est du renseignement
économique.
Donc, vous voyez un gars paumé avec son
saut sur la plage, c'est facile de le
repérer. En Chine, c'est différent. Ils
envoient 5000 mecs sur la plage sans
saut.
Et ce qu'ils font c'est qu' ils
récupèrent les Chinois qui ont été la
plage, il les secours et au lieu de
récupérer un saut de sable, il récupère
25 sauts de sable en secouant petit à
petit les gens qui sont passés sur la
plage.
Peut-être. Pourquoi on dit que il faut
se méfier des Chinoises qui sortent avec
nos marins dans les bases de sous-marins
? Oui, j'ai j'ai un j'ai un très bon ami
Breton qui m'a raconté cette histoire.
Donc du côté de Bres, il me dit il est
stupéfait par le nombre d'officiers
français qui sont séduit par de jolies
chinoises. Donc bon écoutez dire
qu'elles sont belles les Chinoises. Euh
ah ben je écoutez pas dire le contraire.
Je vais pas c'est ça c'est ça que je
veux dire je vais pas vous dire le je
vais pas vous dire le contraire comme
disait un humoriste humoriste chinois
qui faisait des sketchs aux États-Unis
et qui expliquait combien les Américains
étaient différents des Chinois disaient
mais finalement nous ver un point commun
des femmes
chinoises votre ami à Brest ou j'ai un
ami j'ai un très bon ami à Brest donc
qui me qui est très très impliqué et qui
me raconte en effet c'est c'est lui le
premier qui m'a raconté cette histoire
des des des femmes. Écoutez, c'est
possible hein, je je je ne sais rien. Si
c'était vrai, je dirait c'est quand même
de bonnes guerres. Alors c'est c'est une
stratégie mais c'est une strat stratégie
de l'irondel.
Ah non, ça ça c'est une expression
française. Non, l'expression chinoise
c'est le piège de la le piège de la de
la beauté féminine. Donc ça c'est
quelque chose effectivement connu depuis
très très longtemps. Donc pouvoir amolir
l'adversaire par le piège de la de d'une
très bonne ferme. savez que les les
emprunt chinois faisaient ça de façon
régulière, c'est-à-dire que quand il
voulaient faire la paix avec c'est ce
qui se passait avec un roi du Tibet par
exemple, bon ben ce qu'il fait c'est
qu'il lui offrait une concubine. Et vous
avez une concomune très célèbre qui est
la concommune Winchen, donc qui au 18e
siècle donc a dû quitter la cour des
tangs pour aller à l'assa donc épouser
le le le roi tibétain de de de l'époque
et bon donc réaliser les les premières
unions entre le le Tibet et la Chine.
Donc ça ça remonte au 8e siècle. Donc
c'est c'est c'est quelque chose qui
était connu et qui était pratiqué de
façon extrêmement fréquente par la Chine
ancienne. Et pourquoi le gouvernement
chinois dit à ces femmes chinoises
"Méfiez-vous des petits Français ou des
petits
Européens parce que peut-être qu'ils
font la même chose que nous en Chine ?"
Écoutez mais là on posait des questions
sur lesquelles je suis malheureusement
complètement incompétent donc je n'ai
pas de Revenons donc à nos moutons. Le
hard power chinois. Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
? On reviendra. J'ai j'ai mon cadreur
qui montre mon réalisateur qui montre un
truc. Revenons au hard power chinois. Il
y a 25 ans, ils
élèvent une
jeunesse de
guerriers de de de d'enfants dédiés
corps et âme pour la Chine nouvelle.
25 ans plus tard, 2e ou première
puissance économique
mondiale, on se
retrouve avec une Chine qui a mis sous
dépendance
l'Occident, c'est-à-dire il y a eu un
transfert technologique, ils ont bien
appris ou ils ont bien copié, ça dépend
du quel côté on se met.
Maintenant, ils produisent énormément
d'ingénieurs. Ils ont pu mettre sous
dépendance les pays européens en
proposant des produits pas chers de
meilleur de plus de
qualité. Comment comment vous expliquer
? une qualité au départ made in China
c'était très très sous côté mal côté et
maintenant le chinois fait quelque chose
de pas cher à grande quantité et a mis
sous dépendance les populations
occidentales pour maintenir un train de
vie au dépend des
Chinois. Est-ce que ça a été une
stratégie de guerre de faire ça ?
C'est-à-dire de sacrifier son
environnement, de sacrifier sa
population à travailler, travailler,
travailler, travailler pour pouvoir
tenir pratiquement en l'est les
occidentaux sur une grande période.
Est-ce que vous ressentez ça
?
Je j'exprimerai les choses de façon un
peu différente. Je vous en prie. Euh
alors vous vous touchez du doigt un
problème effectivement important qui est
le problème de l'équilibre entre la
consommation et
l'investissement. Donc effectivement
c'est une réalité. On constate que si
vous faites le rapport entre
consommation et
PIB, ce rapport
est de même pour un
pays émergent, un pays comme le Brésil
ou comme l'Inde par exemple, si vous
prenez consommation sur PIB, vous avez
un chiffre de l'ordre de 60
%. Le chiffre dont je dispose pour la
Chine, c'est 36 %.
Donc cette part est extrêmement
extrêmement faible.
Bon alors il est de bon temps de dire
euh oui ça c'est parce que la Chine
dispose de très très peu de de filets de
protection. Il n'a pas de protection
sociale, il y a pas de sec. Respecte pas
les règles de l'OMC. Pardon ? Ne
respecte pas les règles de l'OMC.
Attendez, je je parle pas de ça pour
l'instant. Je parle de de consommation
parce
que la première question que se poser
c'est pourquoi est-ce que les Chinois
consomment aussi peu ? C'est ça la
première question que posé. Parce que si
les Chinois exporent beaucoup, c'est
aussi parce que eux-mêmes consomment
peu. Parce que si consomm c'est s
consommaient beaucoup, ils
expporteraient moins. C'est tout à fait
ce sont des des verres communicants quoi
de ce côté-là. Donc la première question
posé c'est pourquoi est-ce que les
Chinois consomment aussi peu ? Alors,
vous avez beaucoup de d'économistes
syologues qui vous expliquent de façon
convaincante en vous disant que bah
c'est parce que la Chine n'a pas de
filet de protection. Vous n'avez pas de
sécurité sociale, si vous êtes malade,
ben donc ça coûte très cher de vous
soigner. Et puis quand vous prenez votre
retraite, vous avez une retraite très
faible ou pas de retraite du tout. Donc
il faut que vous épargniez pour
pratiquer votre retraite. Bon donc il il
y a certainement du vrai dans ces
arguments, mais je pense que au-delà de
ça, il y a un phénomène culturel qui est
extrêmement important. Et ce phénomè
culturel, il est dû au fait que le
chinois est essentiellement alors non
pas un commerçant comme la plupart des
gens le pensent. Vous savez, c'est
devenu une tarte à la crème. Vous savez
partout on vous dit bah le chinois est
un commerçant né. Non, c'est pas
vrai. Euh le Chinois est un paysan. Donc
la toute la culture chinoise et toute
la toute la la philosophie chinoise est
une culture
paysane. Et le paysan, c'est quelqu'un
qui sait que s'il n'épargne pas,
c'est-à-dire que s'il mange toute sa
récolte, il n'a plus rien à manger
l'année suivante et que il a intérêt
épargner le plus possible parce que non
seulement il faut prévoir les semences
l'années suivantes, mais il faut prévoir
qu'éventuellement il y a des
catastrophes qui se passent et que par
conséquent bon, il peut y avoir des
inondations des sécheresses. Donc il
faut qu'il ait suffisamment de réserve
pour tenir assez longtemps. Et pourquoi
est-ce que je dis ça ? Je vous dis ça
parce que dans ma propre famille, je
vous ai dit que j'ai été élevé à la
chinoise. Et bien dans ma propre
famille, mes parents m'ont toujours
incité à l'épargne et pourtant mes
parents vivaient en France avec un
système français et je bénéficie de la
protection sociale française, je
bénéficie d'une retraite française.
Mais il n'empêche que culturellement,
j'ai toujours été amené à épargner et
mon père m'a inculqué dans mon plus
jeune âge, mon père et ma mère m'a
inculqué que épargner c'est bien et
consommer ses mal. Donc si vous voulez,
vous avez aussi une formation culturelle
qui explique donc cette modestie de la
consommation en Chine. Mais c'est
quelque chose qui est en train de
changer parce que les jeunes générations
sont devenu beaucoup plus intationales,
sont beaucoup
plus enclines à la consommation que les
les anciennes générations et en
particulier ma génération qui est
devenue maintenant très ancienne. Donc
ça si vous voulez c'est c'est la
première c'est la première chose.
Ensuite, pourquoi est-ce que les Chinois
donc produisent temps et et veulent
exporter autant ? Donc et bien c'est
parce
que la Chine a a
compris une chose, c'est l'importance de
la recherche et développement.
Je vais vous décrire un mécanisme qui
est qui est assez peu connu mais qui me
paraît extrêmement important. Il y a un
ouvrage qui est paru en Chine en 2012
qui s'appelle la Chine en
2030 pour une société harmonieuse
créative. Enfin je rappelle plus le
titre Exa. C'est un essai qui a été
conjointement écrit par la Banque
mondiale et par le DRC. Le DRC c'est le
Development Center, c'est le principal
tank chinois. Ils sont à deux. Ils ont
écrit un rapport extrêmement important.
Et dans ce rapport, ce rapport qui est
paru en 2012 est extrêmement important
parce que il a introduit en Chine une
notion qui est connu maintenant les
Chinois qui est la notion du piège de
revenu moyen. Je je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails, mais la Banque
mondiale a démontré que beaucoup de
pays donc émergents dans les années 70
ou 80 ont commençait à
décoller mais arrivé à un certain niveau
de
développement leur croissance s'est mise
à stagner avant de baisser. Donc je vais
pas dans les thèmes mais ce qu'ils
appellent le piège revenu moyen, c'estàd
quand arrivé à à ce niveau qu'on appelle
le revenu moyen et bien ils n'ont pas
réussi à continuer leur leur expansion.
Et la Banque mondiale explique que il y
a une poignée de pays qui ont échappé au
piège sur moyen et ces pays nous les
connaissons. C'est en grande partie
c'est ce qu'on appelait les tigres
asiatiques, Tawan, Hong Kong, Singapour,
la Corée du Sud, enfin donc et pourquoi
est-ce que ces pays ont pu continuer à
se de ont pu échapper au piège du moyen
? Et bien c'est parce que ils n'ont
jamais arrêté la recherche des
développements. Ils n'ont jamais arrêté
d'innover. ce qui leur a permis de
continuer à accroître la productivité,
ce qu'on appelle la productivité totale
des facteurs si on utilise un terme un
peu technique. Et ça, cet ouvrage qui
est pas en 2012 a profondé marqué a
profondément marqué les dirigeants
chinois actuels et notamment le premier
d'entre eux Cimpin qui a compris une
chose que l'avenir donc appartient aux
pays qui vont qui pourront maîtriser
l'innovation et c'est quelque chose
qu'on sait peu donc on a l'impression
que City Pring est quelqu'un de purement
idéologique mais si vous écoutez
attentivement les discours de CP vous
rendrez compte que il y Il y a un mot
qui revient systématiquement dans ces
discours, c'est le mot innovation. Et ce
que veut Sitp avant tout, c'est que la
Chine soit un pays innovant. Et pour que
la Chine soit un pays innovant, il faut
à ce moment-là qu'elle puisse dégager
suffisamment de marges pour pouvoir
investir dans la recherche
développement. Je je je vais donner un
chiffre enfin pour pour donner une
illustration. Vous avez une société que
vous connaissez qui s'appelle
Huawei. Hay vous rappelez c'est la
société que les Américains ont voulu
tuer. Pourquoi ? Ben vous rappelez parce
que c'est c'est la euh c'est la société
qui était en pointe en terme de matériel
de télécommunication de de choses et
donc euh les Américains ont accusé
Huawei d'avoir parti lié avec les
Iraniens. Enfin bon, ils ont trouvé
toutes sortes de raisons et ils ont
voulu pu dire donc ils ont interdit donc
euh aux sociétés américaines d'exporter
les puces les plus modernes à Huawei.
Ils ont interdit à Huawei l'utilisation
de Google de ce qui fait et d'Android
absolument. Donc Google, bon donc ils
ont voulu tout
Huawei. Huawei euh donc a voulu
résister donc et actuellement je donne
les derniers chiffres de Huawei. Huawei
l'année dernière 2024 c'est à peu près
pour s'imper 100 milliards de dollars de
chiffre
d'affaires. Et sur ces 100 milliards de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires, ils
ont ils investissent en recherche
développement 25 milliards de dollars.
25 milliards de dollars, c'est le
chiffre d'affaires de Ericson au Nokia
qui sont les champions européens de
télécommunication. C'est-à-dire que le
champion chinois dépense en recherche
développement l'équivalent du chiffre
d'affaires du champion européen de
Nokia. Donc c'est c'est vous montrer un
petit peu l'importance que les grandes
sociétés chinoises accordent à la
recherche développement. Récemment, vous
avez dû suivre, on a découvert des
l'équivalent de switch sur les panneaux
solaires américains made in China pour
potentiellement créer des
perturbations sur le réseau électrique
américain. Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Ah,
écoutez, alors là, je j'ignore tout tout
ce dont vous parlez. Je je suis pas
courant.
Quand on voit certains groupes de
hackers chinois être cherchés par les
Américains, quand la Chine qui se
prétend ne jamais être
offensive, ne jamais être projeté de
projeter son armée, mais se
projette sur les réseaux à une
stratégie d'infiltration, une stratégie
de conquête, une stratégie ce qui est
appelé du côté chinois défensive.
Nous, de notre regard européen, au
milieu de tout ça, on trouve que c'est
quand même sacrément offensif.
Alors, je je vais faire la réponse. Bon,
il y a il y a quelques temps de cela,
vous avez interviewé, j'ai vu le
passage, l'ancien ambassadeur de chez
Loucha, était à l'époque ambassadeur.
Oui. Et vous lui avez posé la même
question à peu près. Et vous rappelez la
réponse qui vous a donné ? La réponse
qu' donné c'est mais ce sont les
Américains qui nous accusent et sont
très très au courant parce que ce sont
eux qui les premiers ont utilisé ce type
de technique. Donc ils sont beaucoup
plus au courant que nous en réalité.
Voilà ce qu'a répondu si je me rappelle
bien Louchailler à
cette j'ai moins de connaissance que
Loucha parce que c'est pas le domaine
sur lequel je travaille et sur lequel
j'ai prêté beaucoup d'attention. Mais
euh bon, je dirais j'ai trouvé que la
réponse de l'oucha était pas si
mauvaise.
Question internet, est-ce que la Chine
va envahir Taïwan ?
Réponse : Non. Pourquoi ? Parce que
Taïwan c'est la Chine et qu'on envahille
pas chez soi.
Non, c'est parce que ce sera pas
nécessaire. Tout le monde se trompe,
tout le monde pense que la Chine va un
veran.
Mais euh en fait la la enfin pour moi la
la
réunification est inscrite dans les
fêtes et elle va se faire mais la Chine
n'aura pas besoin d'environ et vous
savez grâce à qui cela va pir se faire
notre héros préféré Donald Trump c'est
ça absolument absolument tout à fait
raison c'est Donald Trump vous comprenez
regardez un peu ce qui se passe.
J'ai dit tout à l'heure combien
l'Ukraine enfin la situation Ukraine,
Russie, Taiwan, Chine sont ces
situations sont différentes. Bon,
mais euh quand même ce qu'on peut
constater, c'est quoi ?
Taiwan si Tawan veut son
indépendance, la seule méthode qu'elle
puisse avoir c'est à ce moment-là être
sûr que si le continent chinois attaque
ses pékin pour simplifier attaque ta
Tawan, les Américains viendront à la
rescus de Tawan. Il aussi une deuxième
stratégie, pardon. Il y a aussi une
deuxième stratégie, c'est être capable
de tenir et de faire la guerria un
blocus tellement créer, excusez-moi
l'expression, mais créer à Taïwan un
Vietnam.
Bon,
je je je préfère
simp. Bon, parce que vous allez voir
pourquoi j'écarte cette seconde
hypothèse. Donc c'est c'est le fait que
Tawan puisse dire je déclare mon
dépendance et si le PK m'attaque, ben
j'ai la 7e flotte américaine et Marines
qui débarquent. D'accord.
Donc c'est c'est la seule
chance. Vous comprenez que quand vous
voyez la façon dont Donald Trump traite
l'Ukraine et autres,
bon vous voyez bien combien cette thèse
est crédible ou en tout cas peut-être
sujette à caution. Alors à ce moment-là
quand quand pour un moyen il a le choix
entre deux solutions ou bien
effectivement vouloir maintenir coûte
que coûte son indépendance et risquer à
ce moment-là de subir le sort de
l'Ukraine.
C'est-à-dire bon voyez un peu ce ce qui
se passe, les bombardements donc la la
situation dans laquelle l'Ukraine ou
alors donc essayer de trouver un accord
avec le gouvernement de Pékin pour dire
parce que que veut Pékin ? Quelqu'un
veut simplement si tout veul simplement
que Tawan déclare que Tawan fait partie
de la Chine mais ils ont toujours dit
que à partir du moment où Tabuan
reconnaît fait partie de la Chine, tout
est négociable. Alors bon, que signifie
tout ? Je n'en sais rien. Mais en tout
cas beaucoup de choses sont négociables
à ce momentlà. Alors, vaut-il mieux
trouver un accord avec Pékin donc et
faire en sorte qu'il ait une autonomie
la plus grande possible qui permett à
Tawan de conserver son mode de vie le
plus longtemps possible ou du mieux
risquer la guerre ? Et vous savez quel
est le plus grand allié de Pékin
là-dedans ? Ben, c'est tout simplement
la démocratie. Parce que comme Tawan est
une démocratie, il suffit que vous ayez
une majorité de Tawanés qui disent "Moi,
je préfère négocier avec Pékin plutôt de
courir la guerre pour qu'à ce moment-là
le problème soit résolu." Si les si les
élections se passent dans bonnes
conditions, est-ce que vous allez sur
TikTok ?
Non, TikTok c'est pas de ma génération.
Donc euh je suis sur WeChat, c'est déjà
pas mal. Donc mais euh TikTok enfin vous
savez en Chine j'appelle cying là, c'est
pas c'est pas TikTok. Ça c'est un peu la
même chose mais c'est plus de mon âge.
Quand vous voyez qu'en Chine il ils
poussent les contenus éducatifs auprès
des enfants, ils encadrent
énormément le les écrans pour les
enfants et qu'en Europe et et en aux
États-Unis, en Occident, bah TikTok,
c'est un
peu une guerre cognitive qui ne dit pas
son nom, une guerre cognitive qui
abrutit les gens, qui leur donne leur
dose d'endorphine ou leur dose de
bonheur.
qui ne renforce pas leur intellect.
Est-ce que pour vous c'est une guéri br
une stratégie de sap mur pensé ? Alors
je vais je vais vous rassurer à ma
connaissance d'être rassuré
rassurez-moi je vous rassurer à ma
connaissance les enfants chinois passent
à peu près autant de temps que les les
enfants des autres pays sur sur les
écrans sur sur toin sur les jeux. Bon,
moi je le vois au niveau de mes petits
enfants. J'ai des petits enfants et je
peux vous assurer en France ou en Chine
? Alors, j'en ai en France et j'en ai en
Chine. J'ai tr j'ai trois petits
enfants. Alors, euh les les trois petits
enfants qui sont en Chine, ils ont le
plus jeune à 8 ans et le plus âgé à 20
ans. Bon, et j'en ai aussi en France.
Bon, bien, je peux vous dire que euh en
France euh les les les les parents de
mes petits enfants français sont
beaucoup plus sévères sur l'utilisation
des écrans que les petits enfants
chinois que j'ai. Donc j'allais dire, je
ne suis pas certain qu'il y ait autant
de différence entre la Chine et le reste
du monde. De ce côté-là, chez vous, si
vous m'autorisez à vous poser une
question personnelle, allez-y, allez-y.
Votre table de salle à manger, elle est
rectangulaire ou elle est ronde ?
Ah euh, écoutez, comprenez pourquoi je
pose cette question ? Euh, non.
Alors, elle est ronde ou elle est
rectangulaire votre table ? et ensuite
je vous je vous expliquerai pourquoi.
Alors, d'accord. Ben écoutez, je vais
d'abord essayer de de de répondre aux
questions. Je vais vous dire que quand
je suis en
Chine, j'ai une table à manger ronde et
j'en ai une autre qui est rectangulaire.
J'en ai une troisième qui est carrée
parce que j'ai trois j'ai trois euh
tables
de de salle à manger et quand je suis en
France par que j'ai un porte français ma
ma table est ovale.
Paraît-il que en Chine une table ronde
les places sont très
hiérarchisées. Il y a les vieux les
jeunes, les moins
jeunes. La les places sont très
hiérarchisées autour de la table ronde.
Vous avez connu ça ? Oui, bien sûr.
Expliquez-nous. Bien sûr, j'ai connu ça
mais ça se perd et je peux vous dire per
à cause de Ronald McDonald. À cause de
Ronald McDonald.
Euh enfin peut-être peut-être il y
a-t-il un un lien de cause à effet mais
euh ça se perd parce que les les les
vieilles traditions donc très
hiérarchisées sont actuellement de de
moins en moins de
mise. Vous avez une population chinoise
de
jeune qui finalement est par beaucoup de
côtés assez proches alors qui qui garde
fond chinois mais mais qui par beaucoup
de côté et est quand même assez proche
des des jeunesses que l'on trouve
partout dans le monde. Donc cette
hiérarchie euh et de de familiale et
beaucoup moins connu. Moi moi ce que je
constate donc à la fois auprès de mes
amis chinois et auprès de mes amis
français qui sont de ma génération,
c'est que dans les deux cas, il passe
l'essentiel de leur temps à être les
babysitters de leurs petits enfants.
Donc donc ça c'est un point commun que
je constate à la fois en Chine et en
France, c'est les enfants trouvent très
pratique, très commode de confier leurs
propres enfants à leurs parents. et ça
fait des économies.
Euh c'est pas seulement c'est pas
seulement une question de d'économie,
c'est une question de de de
sécurité, c'est une question
de d'être d'être rassuré parce que c'est
c'est c'est pas le coût d'une garde
d'enfants, c'est le fait qu'ils ont plus
confiance quand même dans leur dans
leurs parents. C'est mamie et papi quoi.
Voilà, c'est ça. Absolument important.
Revenons à TikTok, les écrans, la guerry
hybride. En Chine, c'est les contenus
éducatifs qui sont
poussés. L'algorithme favorise ça. En
Occident, c'est des contenus
abrutissants. À temps égal d'écran, le
petit chinois va apprendre plein de
trucs, le petit occidental va
s'abrutir. Euh, pourquoi c'est fait
comme ça ? Pourquoi l'algorithme en
Chine pousse les contenus éducatifs à
votre avis ? Et pourquoi l'algorithme en
Occident pousse les contenus un peu de
Neux ? Je veux dire, je crois qu'au
départ, le point de départ est le
même. Les gens qui ont
conçu
des activités sur
écran on départ ont imaginé des jeux et
la plupart des jeunes que je vois enfin
je prends des enfants, ils commencent
par jouer à des jeux simplement. On se
rend compte à ce moment-là que ils sont
très habitués aux écrans et ils sont
devenus très très
virtueux. Maintenant, on nécrit
pratiquement plus avec des stylos, avec
du papier, des cahiers, des des des
notes, on ne le fait plus et on
travaille sur écran.
Ce qui fait que les gens qui sont ch
l'éducation se sont en quel ont surfit
sur cette vague et ont utilisé cette
familiarité des écrans pour pouvoir
introduire des contenus éducatifs et
faire en sorte que ils puissent
apprendre et et pas seulement jouer. Je
pense que je me suis mal exprimé. Je
vais je vais répéter ma question.
Il y a des il y a des algorithmes qui
poussent certains contenus. C'est c'est
comme une main invisible du parti de
machin qui font terre certains contenus
qui en favorisent d'autres. En Chine,
c'est les contenus éducatifs qui sont
favorisés avec la même marque en
Occident. C'est des contenus avec des
trucs de dingo pour abrutir, pour rendre
dépendant, pour donner l'opium par
TikTok. Je dirais vous comprenez ce par
oui je commence dire. Ouai. Non mais je
par exemple sur YouTube de temps en
temps ils shadow bannent parce que ils
sont pas contents de certaines choses où
on leur a demandé de faire terre ou de
de masquer ou
d'invisibiliser. Mais je répète ma
question. Jeis bien vraiment être bien
compris. Pourquoi en Chine il propose du
contenu qui renforce le cerveau des
gamins ? Et pourquoi en Europe il il
propose du contenu qui rend un petit peu
euh pas très intelligent ? Alors euh
excusez-moi mais je comprends pourquoi
je n'ai pas compris votre question. Non
non, c'est pas de votre faute du tout.
C'est c'est c'est de la mienne. C'est
que je je ne suis pas dans ce comme je
vous disais, je je ne suis pas
familiarisé. Moi moi moi je moi
j'utilise mon téléphone pour appeler ma
femme et de temps en temps pour prendre
des photos. Donc, mais je ne joue pas à
des jeux, je regarde pas les contenus.
Euh je alors je me considère comme enfin
moi je suis de l'âge de l'ordinateur
portable, c'est-à-dire de l'ordinateur
portable. Oui. De de Est-ce que vous
êtes de l'âge de la plastine avec la
grève de la fin des étudiants ? Oui, je
suis enfin euh je suis un peu plus âgé
que effectivement que
que cette
période. Mais vous savez que c'est c'est
une
véritable tragédie euh cette
personnelle. Mais est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi les choses se sont passées
ainsi
? C'est il y a chose qui est très peu
connue par les gens.
Donc euh en fait euh il se trouve que
j'ai une très bonne amie
chinoise dont dont le père était
ministre des affaires
civiles en Chine à
l'époque et c'est lui qui avait été
chargé par le vent chinois d'aller
négocier avec les étudiants le passion
amen et sa fille donc m'a raconté un
petit peu comment elle sont passés elle
m'a raconté elle m'a appris un élément
extrêmement
important que
j'ignorais et qui explique cette
tragédie. Elle m'explique que son père a
fait tout ce qu'il pouvait pour que les
choses se passent. Donc essayer de
convaincre les les étudiants. Il fallait
qu'ils évacuent leur scan amenun qu'on
ait discuté ensuite que leur
revendication serait
enfin et
systématiquement il a reçu des
rebuffades de la part d'étudiants.
Pourquoi ? Et bien c'est parce que assez
rapidement les étudiants qui étaient sur
place qui étaient euh je dirais entre
guillemets raisonnable ont compris que
les choses avaient mal se passer et
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Ils ont quitté la
P, ils ont été remplacés par des durs.
C'estàd que si vous simplifiez si vous
permet de simplifier ceux qui étaient un
peu mou ont quitté la pass donc et
chaque fois que on a pratiqué la
démocratie directe c'estàd mal levé en
disant qui est pour évacuer la qui est
pour rester comme il restait que des
durs ils sont restés jusqu'au bout et
c'est ça qui a provoqué la tracadier.
Est-ce que le père de votre ami lui a
parlé de la statue érigée par l'école
d'art ? la statue de la déesse
démocratie. Ouais. Vous vous vous savez
que c'est pas une
première. Vous savez que euh la la
déesse de la
démocratie
euh avait été sculpté par les étudiants
lors du mouvement de en
1919. En fait, c'était une reprise de ce
que fait. Et à l'époque, ils
avaient fait deux statutes d'ailleurs,
ça qui est intéressant. Il y avait deux
statutes. Il y avait la statue de la
démocratie et il y avait la statue de
monsieur Science. Rapp surtout, ils
avaient ils avaient fait une statuure.
Vous savez vous savez les les les le le
mouvement de révolte de staff, vous
savez euh euh à quoi il était dû.
Ce qui s'est passé
donc en en mai
1919 euh c'était le le traité de
Versailles qui a mis fin à la Première
Guerre mondiale. Vous savez lorsque le
trait de Versailles a été
conclu à l'époque il fallait décider de
ce que seraient les possessions
allemandes. Bon, on le sait peu mais il
y avait des possessions allemandes en
Chine. C'était le Chintong et notamment
la ville de Cendor. Siendor capitale de
la bière ça dit quelque chose. Donc
c'était en fait une concession
allemande, c'est pour ça que la capitale
de la bière et le TR de Versailles a
décidé de donner toutes les concessions
allemandes au Japon et pas de les rendre
à la Chine alors que la Chine encore une
bonne idée des Européens. Voilà. Alors
que la Chine faisait partie des gérants
du côté des vainqueurs puisque la Chine
avait aidé, vous savez, par l'envoi de
travailleurs, les ouvriers de Renault
qui ne pouvaient plus travailler parce
qu'ils étaient sur le front étaient
remplacés par des femmes et par
notamment les ouvriers chinois. Bon donc
et au lieu de rendre ces territoires à
la Chine, le trait de Vassin a décidé de
les remettre au Japon. Ce qui est
suscité une révolte des étudiants qui
ont trouvé que leur gouvernement était
nul. Comment est-ce que le gouvernement
chinois a pu accepter cette humiliation
? Ça a été la première révolte étudiante
en 1919. Et lors de révol étudiante, les
étudiants ont effectivement euh créé une
statut de monsieur Science et de madame
Alors je crois c'est démocratie
effectivement. Ademmen quel impact ça a
eu sur la jeunesse chinoise ? sur la
jeunesse chinoise.
Écoutez, sur la jeunesse chinoise
actuelle plus
aucune parce que Tian c'est 1989 et la
plupart des jeunes chinois actuellement
donc sont nés après Tiam et et comme on
ne parle pas de Tianamen parce que vous
savez que la censure chinoise interdit
de le faire, les jeunes chinois ne
savent même pas ce qui s'est passé Tian
Amen.
a il y a un espèce d'oubli donc de de
l'ens de la population chinoise. Donc
allez alors je vois
que j'anticipe la question vous allez
poser donc dire que c'est effectivement
toute une stratégie du gouvernement
chinois de faire ça mais à long terme
pardon de long terme de Oui. Mais moi je
vous répondrai que tous les
gouvernements font cela. Euh je vous
donne un autre exemple sur la France.
Bon, la la la France dans lesquelles je
suis euh dans laquelle je suis né après
guerre. Donc moi, toute mon enfance,
encore une fois l'éducation que j'ai
reçu de l'école euh m'a fait croire que
toute la France pendant la second
mondiale était peuplée de
résistants qui ont combattu les
Allemands et toute la période de
collaboration a fait l'objet d'une
censure totale puisque vous
savez je crois ils étaient tous
résistants à la libération c'est ça
pardon ils étaient tous résistants à la
libération donc mais mais non non non
seulement ils Ce sera bon ça c'est une
chose mais mais surtout ce sur quoi je
vais mettre l'action c'est que à l'école
quand on parle la secondaire mondiale on
nous parlait des résistants français on
ne va jamais parler des collaborateurs
français c'est que beaucoup plus tard
que que que et puis vous savez combien
de temps ça vous savez que ça a duré
très très longtemps puisque je crois que
c'est tout à fait récemment qu' est mort
Marceluls donc et son film le chagrin la
pitié vous savez quand il est sorti dans
les 70 était encore censuré. Il n'a
véritablement été autorisé en France que
dans l'année 80. Donc ça ça montre que
tous les gouvernements utilisent quand
même plus ou moins le même type de
méthode et cherchent à faire oublier les
pages sombres ou peu glorieuses de leur
histoire.
Les
gours, on entend beaucoup de choses en
Europe. Nos journalistes nous font
remonter beaucoup de choses. Quand j'ai
interviewé
Louchailler, il nous ont il nous a dit
que bon, c'était des bruits de couloir
de journalistes qui racontaient de la
propagande ou que c'était les
Américains. Les Wigour, comment ils sont
traités par le gouvernement chinois ?
Quand on entend qu'ils sont parqués en
village, que même peut-être qu'il serait
stérilisé, que ils ont un code de
conduite ou une note au-dessus de leur
portes. Qu'est-ce qui se passe avec les
Wigo et la Chine ? Écoutez,
euh il y a beaucoup de de légendes et un
certain nombre de choses qui sont vraies
sur les
Wikours. Moi, moi je dis ce moi, je veux
dire ce que je sais. Bon moi je suis
plusieurs fois au cy
la région desigour à la région région
desigour qui colonisé par les annes
alors euh il faut faire attention faire
attention à ce qu'on dit parce que quand
lesour disent que c'est la terre de
leurs ancêtres et cetera, on se trouve
dans un mécanisme qui n'est pas très
éloigné de ce qu'on trouve en Palestine
dans Israël et la Palestine parce que ça
dépend de quelle époque vous parlez.
Moi, je suis allé au Sinang à plusieurs
reprises et j'ai visité enfin il y a des
a des des villes
anciennes, des des restes des ruines
donc que qu'on peut visiter au Cintiang.
Bon et bien je peux vous dire que toutes
les ruines que j'ai vu étaient de ruines
bouddhistes. Les
gourles, ils ne sont véritablement
arrivés au Cien et ils ont d'ailleurs
massacré les bouddhistes, ils ont
éliminé les bouddhistes qui étaient
avant eux. Mais c'est en gros à partir
du 14e
siècle. Donc c'est à partir de là que
ils ont occupé effectivement le le le
Cynthien. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
maintenant ? Alors, attendez, mais mais
je vais répondre aux questions, mais je
suis obligé de faire un petit rappel
historique parce que sinon on peut pas
comprendre ce qui se passe. Et c'est
vrai que les Wig ont toujours posé un
problème posé un problème euh qui est un
problème très grave, c'est qu'est-ce que
la Chine ? Qu'est-ce que la Chine ? Et
c'est une question à laquelle on ne peut
pas donner réponse très
simple parce que et bon donc vous savez
nous nous vivons dans un système
politique qui est un système
westfallien qui est un système qui est
né de la guerre de 30 ans enfin donc
avec les notions d'état de nation de
religion donc et et tout ça a été mis en
place après les gardes d'Ana avec le
traité de Westfallie
Mais quand on est en Asie, on seet
situation complètement différentes,
c'est-à-dire les espaces qui sont
beaucoup plus grands, avec beaucoup plus
de désert, avec beaucoup moins de
frontières. Bon, donc quand vous avez
une principauté allemande, ben vous
pouvez calculer la frontière au maître
près. Donc en en Asie, on n'est pas dans
ce même genre de de dans ce même genre
de de de situation. Et alors, on peut se
poser question quelle est la Chine ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait l'unité de la Chine ?
La réponse la plus je dirais qui paraît
la plus naturelle, c'est de dire que ce
qui fait l'unité de la Chine, c'est la
culture chinoise et c'est la
culture et ça c'est une thèse qui a été
défendue par pas mal d'historiens dans
les années 30, 20 1920
1930 et vous savez qui défendait le plus
cette thèse d'une Chine culturelle, donc
la Chine Chine des la Chine des hues
provinces mais c'était les historiens
japonais parce que le fait de parler
d'une Chine des Hen ben ça permettait de
délimiter un territoire chinois qui
était plus petit que le territoire de la
Chine actuelle et notamment ça
permettait d'exclure de la Chine des
peuples comme les manchou par exemple et
vous savez que par les Japonais en ont
profité pour créer un état fantoche
qu'on appelait le manchuko donc qui
était un protectorat japonais mais
soi-disant il permettait l'autonomie et
l'indépendance du manchoko par rapport à
la colonisation. Voyez, c'était
véritablement toute une histoire qui
était fabriquée par les japonais. Donc,
mais on revient à cette notion qu'est-ce
que la Chine ? Et c'est la question qui
s'est posée à Soyatsen, le fondateur de
la Bugg. Et Soyatsen a donné sa réponse
en disant la Chine c'est un pays
multiethnique, c'est-à-dire c'est un
pays composé alors à l'époque c'était
six ethniies dont les igours. Mais ça
posait un réel problème parce que c'est
vrai que les igour comme les tibétains
ont une culture qui n'est pas la culture
ha qui est très différente de la culture
haine. Les tibétains, ils sont tibétain
ou ils sont chinois ?
Alors les les Tibétains culturellement
culturellement sont tibétains. Moi je
suis allé plusieurs fois au Tibet. J'ai
beaucoup de respect pour la pour la
culture tibétaine. Le Tibet estant
magnifique. Bon, simplement, je constate
que culturellement les tibétain donc
sont extrêmement religieux donc ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la Chine. Bon, donc
ils ont une culture qui est quand même
très différente de la culture chinoise.
Mais ceci dit, en terme géopolitique, en
terme donc westfalien, le Tibet fait
partie de la Chine. Fait partie de la
Chine parce que tout le monde, tous les
pays au monde le reconnaissent. Il y a
aucun pays au monde qui vous dit le
Tibet est un pays indépendant. Aucun.
Nations- Unies, vous n'avez pas aucune
revendication sur l'indépendance du TIB
si vous voulez. Donc on se trouve face à
cette contradiction contradiction entre
la culture il y a aucun pays. Mais
attendez, je vous ai pas répondu sur une
question de Wigour. Bon donc alors les
les Wigons ont effectivement une culture
qui est différente de de la culture
culture musulmane et en fait il faut
savoir que pendant très longtemps la
Chine a essayé d'intégrer les les lesour
avait une politique extrêmement
favorable auour donc pendant très très
longtemps et ce qu'on a oublié c'est que
il y a eu donc tout un mouvement de
terroriste je sais pas si vous rappelez
terroriste ou de résistants bah
justement le le thème que vous emplez
pas de parallèle avec des conflits. Ben
oui. Ouais. Bon pour pour vous savez que
quand je avais en Chine, vous avez une
voiture conduite par des Wigour qui sont
allés sur le place d'Amen et c'était la
première voiture Bélier en connaissance
qui a tué toute une série de gens sur la
place Tanamen précisément. Donc vous
avez et puis vous avez des desigours qui
sont allés massacrer des Chinois sur une
guerre à première. En fait, vous avez
plusieurs actes de terrorisme et qui se
sont produits. J'appelle ça terrorisme.
Bon, qui sont produits jusqu'au moment
où bon donc le gouvernement chinois a
décidé de de de prendre le tour les
cordes et effectivement a commencé par
interner toute une série de wigour qui
est considérait comme étant dangereux.
Donc bon, moi j'aurais moi moi j'ai pas
la même je dirais euh obligation que que
l'ambasseur Loucha. À ma connaissance,
il y a eu effectivement des camps dans
lesquels on a au début rééduqué les
cours. Réduquer. Qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par rééduquer ? Ben rééduquer,
c'est-à-dire essayer enfin expliquer que
c'est comme ça et que ils allaient
prendre des gros. Mais c'est c'est c'est
le
même c'est c'est le même problème que en
France euh pour les les Français qui
sont allés faire le djihad avec Daesh.
En train de comparer les igour avec les
Daiens ? Mais bien sûr, vous avez Non
mais pas tous lesours, de même que tous
les ne sont pas mort de Daesh, mais vous
avez des wigour chez
Daesh. Vous aviez un certain nombre de
combattantsour, vous en aviez chez les
taliban.
La capitale du Tibet, c'est la ça. Bon,
pourquoi ? Question internet. Quelle
serait selon monsieur Cheng stratégie
politique commerciale diplomatique que
devrait avoir la France avec la Chine ?
Ah, c'est une question sur laquelle j'ai
beaucoup
réfléchi et comme je disais tout à
l'heure, en terme
quantitatif euh vous pouvez pas battre
la Chine. 1500000 ingénieurs produit
chaque année en Chine, 50000 le maximum
par la France. Donc quantitativement
parlant, on peut pas battre la Chine en
France. En revanche,
qualitativement, on le peut en France.
Et moi ce que je remarque c'est que dans
le système éducatif français des grandes
écoles d'ingénieurs produit des
ingénieurs de qualité
exceptionnelle. La la la la qualité des
généurs français est est absolument
exceptionnelle. Donc la créativité
française est exceptionnelle. Il fait
l'admiration des Chinois. Vous savez, je
suis rentré en Chine, les Chinois
étaient b d'admiration sur l'ouverture
jeux olympique en 2024. Ils ont cru que
c'était magnifique. Et vous savez que la
cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
Olympiques françaises a été
intégralement retransmise en Chine
intégralement alors que il me semble que
même en France il y a des passages qui
avaient été censurés des passages qui
sont pas passé la télévision. Oh non
fait pas ça si je crois il y a eu un ou
deux passages je crois. Enfin bon,
c'était quoi votre passage
préféré pour le Dionizos ou c'était le
passage préféré de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des des Jeux Olympiques ?
C'était quoi votre passage préféré ? des
moi moi je veux dire j'étais j'étais
quand même émerveillé par le le final
Céline Dion sur la tour Effel parce que
parce que ce que j'ai trouvé ce qui
était absolument admirable que j'ai
trouvé remarquable dans cette ouverture
c'est que le le véritable héros c'était
Paris et quand quand on voit Céline Dion
qui enfin moi je suis pas grand
spécialiste de la musique mais qui qui
est quand même une star une des plus
grandes en star international quand on
la voit sur deuxème étagefel qui est une
toute petite poupée si vous voulez dans
cette dame de fer, c'est c'est quand
même c'est c'est épustoufflant. Donc
pour moi, c'est un souvenir que que je
garde et je suis pas seul. Les les les
Chinois sont absolument émerveillés par
la créativité française. Donc j'allais
dire si on a la possibilité de pouvoir
marier cette créativité française avec
je dirais le travail des
Chinois, on domine le monde.
Les Chinois ou les Français ? Non. Le
travail des Chinois et la crédité des
Français. C'est mariage entre les deux.
Question internet. Le rattrapage chinois
en matière de développement de puce
informatique accroit-il les risques
d'une offensive militaire contre Taiwan
? Euh, ça le
diminue. Ça diminue pourquoi ? Mais
parce qu'encore une fois, je dis
l'offensive militair est inutile. Il n'y
aura pas d'offensive militaire contre
Twin. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ils font des
exercices de temps en temps à faire des
blocus, faire passer des navires ou à se
mettre tout autour ? C'est juste pour
leur montrer que ils sont là, ils
s'entraînent.
Mais c'est justement c'est c'est c'est
ce qu'on appelle la
dissuasion. C'est c'est c'est pour
montrer parce que encore une fois il va
y avoir un moment où on va poser la
question au tawidé. Qu'est-ce que vous
préférez ? Est-ce que vous préférez
risquer la guerre avec Pékin ou est-ce
que vous préférez qu'on négocie avec
Pékin ? Et pour que le choix pour que le
choix des Taiwan soit en négocié avec
Pékin, il faut que les Twien soient
convaincus que les Chinois possèdent une
supériorité que Pékin possède une
supéorité militaire absolument
écrasante. Vous savez tout à l'heure on
parlait du Le
Frog. Vous savez qu' un exemple du L
frog. Donc je vous disais comment on a
complètement raté le fait que la Chine
développait les véhicules électriques
parce que on constatait que la Chine
avait toujours du retard sur le véhicule
thermique. Bon et bien c'est la même
chose qui est en train de se passer avec
les
portesavions. En terme de porte-avion,
les Chinois sont très en retard sur les
Américains. Qui sont moins moins gros,
ils en ont beaucoup moins. Ils ont ils
font des portes drones. Exactement, ils
font des essins de drone. Effectivement,
avant de parler de technologie
guerrière, je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur la question de notre ami MTA
diplomatiquement parlant. Bon, je sais
que le qued d'ors n'est plus le qued
d'ors de nos aïeux que vous avez
connu. Le qued d'ors il devrait
s'adresser comment à la Chine ? Est-ce
qu'il devrait faire comme Ursula
Vlen sacrifier toute l'industrie
automobile allemande
? Comment on fait pour parler
diplomatiquement à la Chine alors que la
Chine commence à montrer les muscles et
à dire "Toi, petit européen, je te bats
maintenant sur pratiquement tous les
tous les domaines, l'innovation,
l'intelligence artificielle, les
technologies militaires et je te bats en
production d'ingénieur et je te bats en
production d'armement militaire.
Je suis copain avec la Russie, donc j'ai
toutes les matières premières que je
peux avoir que je
veux. Fais pas de ton malin, soumets-toi
où je vais
t'écraser. On le perçoit un peu comme
ça, non ? Ah non, écoutez, les les les
Chinois aussi très volontairement Oui.
Oui. Très très très largement. Non non,
les les les gens n'ont jamais dit "Toi,
petit européen, il disent pas mais nous
nous français, on lit entre les lignes."
Bah vous disait mal. Bon donc non, je je
peut-être que les Chinois s'expriment
mal.
Pourquoi ? Bah soit je lis mal, soit
c'est ou soit soit je suis bête. Non
mais vous comprenez en fait cette
subtilité de langage de compréhension et
d'échange culturel. Peut-être on n'est
pas
aligné. Je suis pas sûr. Non. Ce ce que
je peux vous dire moi, c'est que moi je
vis en Chine la plus grande partie de
mon temps et comme je dis depuis 20 ans.
Bon, vous avez combien de crédits social
? Vous êtes à 100 %. H écoutez euh alors
plus de parent sur les crédit social, je
sais pas très très bien ce qu'on appelle
les crédit. À ma
connaissance, le le seul euh domaine
dans lequel on parle vraiment de crédit
social, c'est quand il faut que vous
alliez emprunter de l'argent à la
banque. Bon et comme moi j'emprunte pas
d'argent à la banque, je ne sais pas
quel est mon crédit social et je m'en
fiche pour dire pour vous dire ce qu'il
bon. Vous avez des réductions euh sur
les billets d'avion ? Vous avez des
réductions avec vos crédit social ? Vous
avez pas remarqué ? Non, non, mais pas
du tout. Mais ça rien à voir du tout.
Moi, moi je prends des billets d'avion t
tous les enfin de façon très fréquente.
Vous êtes français, vous êtes pas
chinois ? Je suis français. Oui, je suis
français, je suis pas chinois. Bon, mais
enfin, j'ai des amis chinois qui
prennent des avions. On n jamais posé la
question sur le crédit social pour avoir
des réductions sur les non. Euh ça ça se
passe de façon négative. C'est-à-dire
que euh quand vous avez des gens qui
sont condamnés, quand vous avez des gens
qui font faillite ou quand vous avez des
gens qui doivent de l'argent par
exemple, bon bien à ce moment-là, le
créancier peut attaquer le débiteur et
si le débiteur est condamné par un
tribunal, alors à ce moment-là, le
débiteur peut se trouver empêché. Donc
le tribunal a la possibilité d'empêcher
euh le le début en question de prendre
l'avion, de de de prendre même le train
parfois. Donc et il y a toute une série
de gènes dans sa vie quotidienne qu'il
rencontre. Donc
mais c'est pas le enfin voyez c'est
c'est un enfin si on peut dire c'est un
espèce de crédit social à l'envers,
enfin négatif qui se crée et qui mais il
faut que vous soyez condamné par un
tribunal pour ça. C'est pas quelque
chose que vous pouvez pas quitter le
pays par exemple. Bon donc c'est c'est
dans ce cas-là. Mais sinon, autrement,
je je n'ai je n'ai pas rencontré dans ma
vie
quotidienne la notion de crédit social.
Je vais vous lire quelques questions
internet, on va les prendre à la
volée. Si la Chine ne prépare pas une
invasion de Taiwan, pourquoi tester des
immenses barges servant à des
débarquements ? Autre question. Si la
Chine ne compte pas envahir Taiwan,
pourquoi dépense-t-elle autant d'énergie
à développer ses propres technologies de
lthographie de puce ? Question internet.
Que pense monsieur T de la loi chinoise
de 2017 sur le renseignement et en
particulier son article
7. Pourquoi n'y a-t-il pardon, c'est un
peu trop loin. Pourquoi n'y a-t-il n a
n'y a-t-il que très peu de prix Nobel
chinois malgré le nombre de stè ? Bon,
est-ce que questions tout intéressantes
? Je vais essayer de me les rappeler.
Bon, sur les questions des barges. Alors
ça, je reviens toujours la même chose.
Pour que Pékin convainque les Taiwanés
de négocier avec Pékin, il faut que
Pékin montre qu'en cas de guerre, les
Taiwanés n'ont aucune chance. Donc, il
faut montrer des armes extrêmement
puissantes. C'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure, vous m'avez interrompu quand
j'ai parlé et parce que vous avez
compris ce que j'allais dire. Les
chinois on ont créé des portes drones.
Bah c'est pour montrer que s'il y avait
une guerre, les n'auraient aucune
chance. Mais les Chinois ont l'arme
nucléaire. Les les Chinois ont l'arme
nucléaire. Oui, mais on on va pas C'est
contreproductif. Non, non, on va pas
employer euh la la bombe atomique sur
Taiwan. Euh bon donc ce qu'on cherche à
démontrer enfin ce que Pékin cherche à
démontrer à Tawan c'est que si faisait
le choix de la guerre encore une fois il
n'aurait aucune chance donc c'est pour
les incit donc la le fait de développer
des armes extrêmement puissantes et
modernes est destiné à ne pas s'en
servir à montrer queon a une force de
frappe considérable pour surtout ne pas
s'en servir et pour pouvoir dissuader
par conséquent l'étaté de ch indépendant
donc ça c'est la réponse à la fait la
même chose avec les États-Unis. Alors ça
euh c'est euh alors de façon
différente. Oui, en terme de mais de
façon différente. Comment ça ? Ben tout
simplement par le fait que quand quand
vous regardez, vous savez quelles sont
les dépenses militaires, les États-Unis
dépensent à peu près, je crois 800
milliards de dollars par an ou 900
milliards de dollars par an de dépenses
militaires. La la Chine, c'est trois
fois moins. Je peux vous poser une
question ? Combien ça coûte de faire un
slip aux États-Unis et combien ça coûte
de faire un slip en Chine ? Très bonne
question. Ah, ça coûte combien ? Trois
fois moins, hein ? Un trois fois moins.
Oui. Voir c fois moins. Oui, c'est ça.
Peut-être 10 fois. Alors, écoutez, je je
connais moins les États-Unis parce que
parce que j'y vais moins souvent donc et
mais je connais enfin je peux vous faire
le cette comparaison entre la France et
la Chine, je peux vous dire compris ma
comparaison entre les Bien sûr, bien
sûr. Et l'armement bien sûr, bien sûr.
Tout à fait. Donc vous me dites que la
dépense militaire chinoise, c'est trois
fois moins que les
États-Unis. Sauf qu'en terme
d'efficacité et de productivité, mais
c'est 10 fois plus en fin de compte.
Peut-être, mais je j'utilise j'utilise
les chiffres que la plupart des
spécialistes de géopolitique et de
d'armement utilisent. Donc, je ne fais
que rabâcher comme un berroquet ce ce
qu'on dit pour vous. de terrain. Vous
êtes
polytechnicien, vous n'êtes pas comme un
Attendez un Écoutez alors vous prenez
une chose. Un polytechnicien est un
homme de terrain. Ben je suis très
flatté de le savoir. Non mais c'est que
vous vous êtes polytechnicien et en plus
vous êtes un homme de terrain. Ah
écoutez, je vous remercie du compliment.
Ouais bon bon ce n'est peut-être pas le
cas de nos experts militaires. Bon ouais
peut-être. Alors non mais mais je je je
vais continuer je vais continuer ma
réponse à votre question sur les
États-Unis. Alors ce que fait la Chine
en revanche, c'est que comme la Chine ne
veut pas attaquer les États-Unis,
heureux,
bon mais elle craint
éventuellement elle elle craint
éventuellement d'être attaquée par les
États-Unis. Donc euh elle est en train
de développer euh ce qu'on appelle des
armements
asymétriques. C'est-à-dire que elle ne
cherche pas à avoir la supéorité sur les
Américains pour toutes les armes. Elle
cherche simplement à avoir une
superorité sur un certain nombre
d'armes. Et si vous regardez
attentivement ce que les Chinois
développent comme arme, il y en a deux
essentiellement. L'intelligence
artificielle l'intelligence avec les
superattaques he drones et les drones.
Non pas les drones. Enfin les drones
c'est nouveaux mais quand états c'est
pas ça. États-Unis ce que les Chinois
sont en train de développer ce sont les
missiles
hypersoniques. Les Russ leur ont donné
non c'est pas les Russes qui ont donné
les Chinois ont développé ça par leur
propre par leur propre moyen. Les
Chinois ont développé des des missiles
passion ils ont fait un test il y a il y
a 2 ans de cela. Ils ont envoyé un
missile. Alors vous savez à quoi ça sert
un missile personnel ? Ça sert à à
frapper le premier ou à répondre plus
vite ? Non, c'est pas ça. Le missile des
Chinois ont un surnom son de
porte-avion, c'està-dire ce sont des
missiles qui vont tellement vite que les
inerciel que non non que les
antimissiles des des porte-avions
américains ne peuvent pas les abattre
parce qu'ils vont trop vite. Quelle est
la faiblesse des missiles hypersoniques
? C'est qu'ils vont extrêmement vides
mais sont peu précis.
ce les les missiles hypersoniques russes
sont relativement précis quand même. Je
je vous parle pas de missil pas russe,
je parle des missioniques chinois. Je ne
sais pas s'ils sont les mêmes. Est-ce
que vous connaissez les torpilles
hypersoniques ? Euh non, je connais pas.
Non. C'est comme un missile hypersonique
mais sous l'eau. Sous l'eau. Ouais. Bon
écoutez peut-être mais les Américains
ont cette technologie depuis 91. Ouais
mais ouais ils ont piqué un un chercheur
français qui s'appelle Jean-Pierre
Petit.
Les Chinois ont copié tout le monde, les
Russes ont copié tout le monde mais à la
base c'est une technologie française.
Mais alors je je dis pas SP c'est
larmement mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est
au niveau de de l'idée c'est que les
Chinois sont en train de développer ces
armes qui sont essentiellement destinées
à tenir à distance l'armée américaine.
C'est-à-dire que l'idée c'est d'avoir
des armes qui soient suffisamment
efficaces pour que les portavions
américains ne s'approchent pas des côtes
chinois. C'est quoi c'est ça ? C'est
c'est ça que j'appelle la gaz étrique,
donc l'intelligence artificielle avec
les cyberattaques. Donc et c'est c'est
quand même tout à fait effant quand vous
regardez un peu ce qui ce qui s'est
passé en en Espagne avec le blocout de
l'Espagne où ce qui s'est passé sur la
Côte d'Azur il y a quelques jours. Donc
et et si on peut si on se rend compte
qu'on est capable de de d'attaquer des
réseaux électriques, enfin on voit un
peu les dégâts que ça fait sur l'Espagne
simplement. Pour vous c'est une
cyberattaque en Espagne ? Ah non non, je
b c'est une attaque. Je je ne suis pas
du tout compétent là-dessus mais je dis
simplement que à mon
avis donc on a les moyens par une
cyberattaque d'arriver au même résultat.
Très vrai. Deuxème question je vous la
relis. Oui. Donc on a fait les
barges. On a fait la lographie des puces
de Taiïwan. Alors la la lthographie des
puces de de Taiwan. Alors, vous savez
que là encore les Chinois remercient
Trump. Trump est en train d'accélérer
considérablement le développement des
des des puces
chinoises. Vous avez vu ce qu'a dit
Jenon Hang à ce sujet. Vous savez qui
est Jensen Jang ? Dites-moi. C'est le
président de Nvidia. Le président de
Nvidia. Action, elle va pas très bien en
ce moment. Non. Ben, justement à cause
de monsieur Donald Trump.
Monsieur Donald Trump pense qu'en
n'empêchant la vente de puce de haute
tech notamment Nvidia à la Chine, il va
entraver le développement de la Chine.
Ce qu'a dit monsieur Johnson Hang il y a
pas longtemps, c'est de dire "Mais en
réalité, c'est une erreur
considérable. Il faut faire le
contraire. Il faut encourager la Chine à
acheter des puces américaines, notamment
Nvidia. Bon, évidemment, il prêche pour
sa paroisse, mais il a un argument qui
est quand même très intéressant. Il dit
quel est le business model Nvidia ? Ben
Nvidia, nous sommes connus parce que
nous nous créons et nous fabriquons des
puces de dernière génération, celles qui
font 3 nanom, 2 nanomè et cetera. Bon
donc mais pour arriver à réaliser ce
type de puce, il nous faut dépenser
énormément d'argent en recherche
développement. D'où vient cet argent ?
de cet argent vient des bénéfices que
nous retirons en vendant des puces de
génération bien moins avancées aux
Chinois qui nous les payent et sur
lesquels on fait des marges
considérables qui nous permettent de
développer nos puces de la génération,
d'avoir toujours un coup d'avance,
d'avoir même plusieurs coups d'avance.
Quand monsieur Donald Trump nous empêche
de vendre ses puces de génération
anciennes aux Chinois, il va d'une part
inciter les Chinois à développer ses
propres puces et comme c'est des puces
de génération anciennes, les Chinois
vont y arriver.
Et non seulement ils vont y arriver,
mais compte tenu de la capacité
chinoise, ils vont même faire ses puces
moins chers que nous. Donc ils vont nous
concurrencer sur notre marché. Ils vont
nous couper nos bénéfices. Ce qui fait
que n'ayant pas de bénéfices, on ne
pourra plus développer des puces de
dernière génération. Il y a pas un
proverbe chinois qui dit "Ne tue pas ton
ennemi mais attends que son cadavre
passe devant toi dans la rivière." C'est
ça. Non,
je je connais pas ce question internet
sur les prix Nobel. Sur les prix Nobel.
Très bonne question
d'ailleurs. Alors, écoutez, c'est une
très bonne question que je me suis
beaucoup posé. Alors, je vais vous
dire, j'ai remarqué une chose très
intéressante, c'est
que euh la
Chine, j'ai j'ai posé cette question à
des scientifiques français.
tout à fait neutre. Qu'est-ce que vous
pensez niveau de recherche chinois ? Et
le le le le scientifique français m'a
répondu que en fait il y a quand même un
problème en
Chine, c'est le respect du
maître. C'est-à-dire
que
les les étudiants chinois sont très bons
élèves qui respectent leur maître. Donc
ils apprennent très bien ce qu'enseigne
le maître. Bon mais si vous voulez donc
et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont très bon
dans toutes sortes d'innovations
incrémentales enfin de
d'innovation oui ce qu'on appelle
l'innovation incrémentale interdit de
dépasser le maître mais mais si vous
voulez vraiment faire ce qu'on appelle
des innovations de rupture il faut
savoir tuer le maître et ça les chins
n'osent pas. Donc il y a il y a un
problème un peu général. Alors, vous
avez tellement chinois que vous avez
quand même des Chinois qui qui sont
capables effectivement de de de de faire
des inventions, mais en effet pour
l'instant, il y en a pas eu qui sont
arrivés au niveau du prénom.
Je répète cette question d'ailleurs, je
je ne connaissais pas. Que pense
monsieur Cheng de la loi chinoise de
2017 sur le renseignement et en
particulier son article 7.
Écoutez là là je ne suis je ne suis pas
juriste et j'avoue humblement que je ne
sais pas de de question est-ce que le
système de Uku perdure toujours dans la
Chine moderne ? Oui c'est c'est le
RO le le rouro perdure dans la Chine
moderne mais il est devenu très perm.
Alors vous savez qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Bon alors qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que c'est
que le Rocro ? Le le rocro est un
système en quelque sorte de de de
passeport à l'intérieur du
pays. C'est-à-dire que quand vous
naissez, on vous donne un rouro qui est
un peu comme une espèce de carte
d'identité et qui rattaché votre lieu de
naissance et qui vous suit pendant toute
votre vie mais avec des consciences
pratiques qui sont quand même très
importantes. Par exemple, quand vous
avez le rouro d'une ville, je sais pas
de Nimigour, une villeour d'une ville
ouigour par exemple et bien vous êtes
assez donc vous êtes censé aller faire
vos études là. Je je donne cet exemple.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est c'est le cas
de mon petitfils. J'ai un petitfils à à
Shanghaiï. Il est chez vous français.
Alors euh pour l'instant il n'a pas
encore choisi parce que son père et mon
fils donc il est français mais sa mère
est est chinoise, elle est de tiensin.
Donc pour l'instant il a encore le choix
entre les deux nationalités. il faudra
que il choisisse à à 18 ans. Bon donc
mais quand il était enfant, quand il est
arrivé à Changaré et bien il a eu des
problèmes d'éducation parce que comme le
rouro de sa mère auquel était rattaché
est un rou de Tientin, il était censé
aller faire ses études à Tientin alors
que les parents, c'est mon fils et ma
belle-fille sont à Shanghai donc
finalement ils sont allés au lycée
français de Shanghaï. Bon donc pour euh
résoudre cette question mais c'est pour
vous expliquer ce qu'est leukro et
leukro fait que par exemple vos
précessions sociales donc l'éducation
enfin tout ce qui concerne la société
donc est rattaché au votre lieu de
naissance en quelque sorte bon donc ça
limite évidemment considérablement la
mobilité des Chinois à l'intérieur du
pays c'est les Chinois ne peuvent pas
s'établir là où ils veulent alors que
c'est leur propre pays donc on parle de
l'abolition du recours depuis très très
longtemps, mais il faut savoir que en
Chine, on est dans une logique
législative qui est l'inverse à la
France. En France, on passe beaucoup de
temps à élaborer des lois, des cré
d'application. Une fois que la loi est
élaborée, paf, on l'applique. D'accord ?
En Chine, c'est l'inverse. C'està-dire
qu'en Chine, on commence par appliquer
un nombre de choses qui sont contraires
à la loi, donc et on le fait de façon
illégale, mais donc on va un peu aux
limites de la loi, mais pour tester un
peu et pour voir la la faisabilité et
l'impact social que ça peut avoir. Et
quand ensuite le gouvernement se rend
compte que ça marche, et bien à ce
moment-là, il a boulé la loi précédente
et il fait une nouvelle loi. Mais la
nouvelle loi qu'il met en place a déjà
été appliquée depuis des années. Donc
c'est c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer avec le Rouro, c'est-à-dire que
petit à tout petit à petit le train de
s'effriter mais il n'a toujours pas été
aboli. Et quand il sera aboli, bah ce
sera en fait une écorce vide quoi. Vous
avez entendu que la Chine allait
chercher ses dissidents ou
ses son ses habitants contestataires à
l'étranger ou très
critique. Ça vous fait penser à quoi
? Vous avez entendu aussi l'ouverture de
commissariat chinois de l'ombre
? Ça me fait pas penser à grand-chose.
Euh
donc euh
bon vous avez compris que je ne suis pas
un dissédent chinois et je ne fréquente
pas les dissédents chinois. Donc est-ce
que le fait que vous ayez votre fils en
Chine, le gouvernement chinois a essayé
d'appliquer des pressions sur vous pour
que vous soyez plutôt bienveillant dans
votre approche de votre lecture de la
Chine ? Non, jamais. Non, jamais. Donc
je moi je Bon, vous connaissez le nouvel
ambassadeur ? Non, je connais pas le
nouvel ambassadeur. Vous connaissiez
Loup, la légende ? Et je je je
connaissais tous les ambassadeurs
précédents, mais le nouvel ambassadeur
est est trop nouveau. Il est
francophone, il il est il parle très
très bien français et il est à la fois
francophone et francophile donc et je
sais que non seulement alors non
seulement lui est francophone est
francophone mais sa femme l' aussi. Donc
c'est un couple donc très très
francophone et et très francophile.
C'est tout ce que je sais mais je ne le
connais pas personnellement.
En général, quand on a un diplomate
chinois en face de nous, c'est le
meilleur de meilleur du meilleur sur
1ARD4000
habitants. Qu'est-ce
que Comment vous percevez ça ? Le fait
que l'élite
chinoise est issue d'un processus
d'ultra sélection pour défendre la Chine
? Quel regard vous portez maintenant sur
la France quand vous voyez ça en Chine
avec une population en 25 ans qui s'est
redressé degré ou de force, je dirais.
Et quand vous voyez la nonchalance
française, est-ce que vous essayez de
dire à vos compatriotes
français "Allô, on se réveille, les
Chinois, c'est quand même le dragon".
C'est c'est c'est pour moi
euh un grand sujet de j'allais dire de
de moquerie. Non non pas pas du tout de
moquerie. Non non pas pas c'est pas du
tout de moquerie parce que parce que je
sais pas si vous rendu compte mais moi
moi j'aime beaucoup la France. Je suis
français quand même je je suis français.
J'estime que la France m'a beaucoup
donné ne soit ce qu'au niveau de mes
études si vous voulez et je trouve qu'il
est de mon devoir aussi de rendre à la
France une partie de ce qu'elle m'a
donné. Donc moi j'aime beaucoup la
France et je j'avoue que je suis aussi
assez désespéré parce que je vis en
Chine de regarder ce que la France
devient à partir de à partir de la
Chine. Et alors en fait je me polarise
je dirais sur un élément qui me paraît
absolument essentiel et qui moi me
désespère c'est l'éducation en France si
vous voulez. Moi moi je
suis le résultat de de la sélection
française. Mes parents des immigrés
chinois et qui ne sait pas grand-chose
au système français. Mais à l'époque où
je étude, il y avait un système sélectif
français qui marchait très bien et qui
faisait que finalement les les on fait
que je me suis retrouvé dans le maire
lycée de Marseille et que là je suis
allé faire donc je suis allé en mp enfin
je dire j'ai été poussé par le système
éducatif et je rappelle encore donc
comme comme on est assim que j'étais un
fils de d'immigré à un moment on m'a mis
dans un lycée de de de de secondes zone
à Marseille. Bon parce que le meilleur
lycée c'était le lycée tiers de de de
Marseille et bon on trouvait que j'étais
sans doute pas digne du lycée tire. Donc
j'ai fait ma 6e ma 5e dans un autre
lycée qui s'appelait le lycée Pierre
Puget à Marseille. Et je rappelle encore
le professeur principal qui est en
classe 5, enfin classe 5e m'a dit euh
"Écoutez euh moi je trouve que c'est
dommage
que euh vous restiez dans votre lycée
parce que vous avez largement le niveau
pour aller au lycée tiriez pas aller
létien je dit mais écoutez monsieur oui
moi je demande que cela mais on ne veut
pas de moi l tiè dit écoutez si vous
voulez laissez-moi faire m dit mais
faites une chose demander à faire du
grec et j'urai votre demande. C'est ce
que j'ai fait. On sait que j'ai fait du
grec. Bon et comme il y avait lycée tiè
où on enseignait le grec et bien on m'a
mis au lycée tire avec la recommandation
de mon professeur. C'estàd que ce
professeur qui était professeur Pierre
Pugé il m'a dit je suis brur laissé
perpugé mais je trouve que c'est dommage
que vous continuez vos études ici parce
que il faut que vous allez le cé et
c'est c'est grâce à lui que je suis que
j'ai j'ai déposé comme ça.
la la la sélection euh
française donne quand même des des
résultats qui sont qui sont
extraordinaire donné et donné et et et
quand maintenant je me rends compte que
quand on de sélection c'est un gros mot
je veux dire ça ça me ça me
désespère question internet pouvez-vous
nous expliquer ce qu'il reste de
l'héritage marxiste dans le communisme
chinois.
Ah euh le communisme. Alors moi j'ai une
formule. Je dis que la Chine est un rég
est un
régime communiste marxiste
darwinien. Qu'est-ce que je dire par là
? Ce que je veux dire, c'est
que le le marxisme si vous écoutez
soigneusement la les discours
chinois, les discours chinois, donc ce
que les Chinois eux-mêmes disent, ils
vous disent que la Chine est un pays
marxiste
léniniste donc enrichi par la pensée de
Manetour, donc par la pensée de T
Shopping, par la théorie de de donc des
trois représentativités, le
développement scientifique et cetera.
C'est-à-dire que le le le marxisme
chinois, il faut bien comprendre une
chose, la Chine n'est pas un p ce n'est
pas un pays où il y a une religion du
livre. Les pays que nous connaissons que
soit la France, en Angleterre, les pays
musulmans, les juifs, les catholiques,
les protestants sont tous des gens qui
faire un livre.
Et quand vous avez un livre dans lequel
vous avez la vérité qui est écrite, vous
allez essayer de comprendre la vérité et
vous allez vous référer à ce livre.
C'est la Torah, c'est la Bible, c'est le
Coran, c'est tout ce que vous voulez. La
Chine est un pays où vous n'avez pas de
livres qui vous donnent la
vérité. Donc ce que ce que livre rouge
quand
même, c'est alors attendez, je vous
parle de religion là pour l'instant.
C'est pas une religion le petit livre
rouge. Non, c'est pas une religion. Donc
et maintenant on en parle plus
d'ailleurs. Donc mais euh
philosophiquement c'est important. C'est
parce que vous avez tous les pays que
vous connaissez les États enfin que tous
les pays occidentaux sont des pays où
vous avez une philosophiement
culturellement cette notion de vérité
qui est inscrite dans un livre qui
n'existe pas en Chine. Ce qui veut dire
que le marxisme n'est pas un dogme donc
continu et immuable. Au contraire, la
Chine considère que une théorie, quelle
qu'elle soit doit sans cesse s'adapter
aux conditions dans laquelle et c'est
c'est pour ça que j'appelle ce marxisme
chinois
darwinien, c'est parce que alors voyez
quel a été le grand apport de de de
Topping au marxisme ? Et bien c'est que
Tony Hopin a adapté le marxisme à la
situation chinoise, le marxisme
économique à la situation chinoise en
disant c'est ce qu'on appelle le
marxisme aux caractéristiques chinoises.
Quelle a été l'apport de Cimpin ? Vous
le savez son livre ? Vous avez lu son
livre ? Euh enfin il a pas écrit livre.
Ce qu'on publie ce sont des recueux de
discours. Donc j'en ai lu j'en ai lu
quelques-uns. Effectivement gros livre
blanc là. Ouais non il y en a plusieurs.
Il y a plusieurs tomes maintenant. Il y
a d'autres tomes qui ont été publiés.
Bon donc c'est ce sont les discours de
de de C. J'en ai lu quelques-uns mais
j'avoue que j'ai pas tout lu. Mais le
premier tome est quand même très
passionnant le le premier tome
effectivement il y a toute une série de
de de choses qui qui sont écrites
là-dedans. Mais le grand apport
théorique de Cin Tapin a adapté le
marxisme aux caractéristiques
chinoises. Cimpinpin adapte le marxisme
à l'époque moderne. Donc il dit c'est le
marxisme pour une nouvelle ère. Donc
vous voyez euh pour les Chinois ce qui
est important c'est que ce soit le
marxisme ou n'importe quoi, il doit tout
le temps
s'adapter à la nouvelle époque et
s'adapter aux nouvelles conditions. Vous
savez, je je fais souvent un parallèle
qui va peut-être vous étonner. Je je
fais le parallèle. Je je dis que vous
avez deux institutions au monde. Il y a
plus que deux institutions au monde qui
sont les plus anciennes et qui sont
encore vivantes aujourd'hui. Vous savez
ce qu'elles sont ? Il y en a une, c'est
la bureaucratie
chinoise et l'autre la bureaucratie
française. Non, c'est le Vatican. Ah,
pas mal.
et le meilleur système de renseignement
du monde d'ailleurs. Donc donc ce sont
les deux institutions qui sont à la fois
les plus anciennes et les plus vivantes
de de nos jours et je suis très
admiratif enfin voyez élection du pape
très admiratif de la façon dont le
Vatican arrive à adapter la région
catholique au monde moderne. C'est
remarquable et si vous voulez le la bure
alors je parle la burecie chinoise qui
est beaucoup plus ancienne et à mon avis
plus importante que le parti communiste
chinois. La femme chinoise est-ce que
c'est comme il y a 25 ans une femme
soumise à son homme qui allume des
cigarettes à tout le monde pendant le
mariage ou est-ce que la femme chinoise
maintenant est devenue une working girl
indépendante une machine de guerre ?
Écoutez, qu'est-ce que je voudrais
qu'une femme chinoise soit comme vous la
décrivez là dans au départ
? C était mon rêve. Malheureusement, ce
rêve n'a jamais été réalisé. Bon, dans
sans
plaisanter euh bon honnêtement le le
sort de la femme
chinoise n'est pas tout à fait comme
celle de la la française, de
l'américaine et cetera. Donc, on n' pas
encore cette égalité.
entre entre l'homme et la femme. Et ça
se voit notamment au niveau de la
politique, au niveau du politique. Si
vous prenez le bureau politique qui
rassemble actuellement les 24 personnes
les plus puissantes de Chine, il y a pas
une seule femme. Donc mais ceci dit, les
femmes urbaines sont devenues
extrêmement extrêmement dépendantes. Et
je dirais ça la chose suivante, c'est
que le sort de la femme chinoise est
très supérieur au sort de la femme
japonaise ou de la femme
coréenne. Je connais énormément de
femmes coréennes qui sont venues en
Chine pour épouser des Chinois et pour
dire "Je cherche la liberté en Chine
parce que je n'ai pas en Corée." Votre
Brue, vous l'avez marié à la française
ou à la chinoise ? Ah ben attendez ma
Brue. Alors c'est pas moi qui l'ai
trouvé, c'est mon fils qui l'a qui l'a
trouvé et ils se sont mariés euh bon
enfin ils ont fait une cérémonie en
rouge ou en blanc.
Écoutez euh le le leur mariage n'a pas
été un mariage très très traditionnel.
Donc alors ma femme l'aurait voulu. Ma
femme voulait que je puisse louer un
palanquin, vous savez, de traditionnale
rouge dans lequel on enferme la mariée
et le le marié en fait découvre sa femme
en ouvrant les rideaux du palanquin.
C'est ça ce qu'on faisait en donc ma
femme voulait garder ça. Moi j'ai trouvé
que c'était quand même un petit peu
ringard. Donc j'ai fait en sorte que ça
ne marche pas. Bon ils ont fait un
mariage tout à fait. Non non écoute elle
vous en veut énormément. C'est ça. Ma ma
femme ben écoutez, ma femme m'en veut de
toute façon de façon systématique depuis
très très longtemps. Donc j'en ai j'en
ai l'habitude et ce n'est que une petite
goutte parmi le l'océan de plein de
canard. Qu'est-ce que vous l'aimez
d'ailleurs votre femme ? Qu'est-ce que
vous l'aimez votre femme ? Ça fait
combien de temps que vous êtes marié ?
Écoutez, c'est alors je vais raconter ce
qui s'est passé.
Donc quand j'ai épousé la femme au bout
de au bout de quelques temps, j'ai un
jour j'ai eu le malheur de lui poser la
question. Je lui ai dit "Est-ce que je
t'ai rendu heureuse ?" Vous savez ce
qu'elle m'a répondu ? Elle me dit "Mais
quelle question stupide ! Ça ne fait que
10 ans que nous sommes mariés. Comment
veux-tu que je réponde ?" Alors je me
suis abstenu posé. Alors maintenant, ça
fait 47 ans que nous sommes mariés. Je
pense que je vais pouvoir bientôt lui
reposer cette question mais j'ai pas
encore osé le faire. Et vous lui posez
la question en français, en anglais ou
en chinois ? Alors, écoutez, je suis
idiot euh comme tous les
maris. C'est-à-dire que donc nous
parlons les trois langues en effet. Bon,
la langue que je marie le mieux, c'est
le français. Elle c'est l'anglais bien
entendu et entre les deux, nous avons le
chinois. Et vous vous engueulez en
français, en anglais ou en chinois ?
Mais on s'engueule en anglais évidemment
parce que elle a la supériorité sur moi
et comme je suis bête, je me fais
toujours avoir par
elle. Qu'est-ce que vous voulez ? Bon,
est-ce qu'on peut parler des Ghost Town
et de Evergreen ? si vous voulez. Non,
Everground pardon Evergr
Lego Town. Bon alors les les Gostown bon
il faut comprendre la la naissance de la
crise chinois la crise la la crise
économique chinoise actuelle est
essentiellement une crise
immobilière. Il faut comprendre
l'origine de la crise immobilière que
que personne n'a vraiment décrit. Cette
crise immobilière remonte en fait en
1995.
Ça fait 30 ans de ça.
À quoi est-elle d ? Elle est en fait à
une réforme extrêmement importante qui a
été faite par le premier ministre de
l'époque enfit qui était même pas
premier ministre des vice-premier
ministres qui étaient tout gentil.
Quand Jonenti qui qui a été sans doute
le plus grand premier ministre chinois
de ces 40 dernières années, quand Jonti
est arrivé à son poste, il s'est rendu
compte que le système fiscal chinois
faisait que les impôts étaient collectés
par les provinces et les provinces
remettaient une partie gouvernement
central. Ce qui fait que le gouvernement
central était toujours à cours d'argent
et tout à constater un jour que le
premier ministre de l'époque était
vice-pr ministre qui était l'pring était
obligé de décrocher son téléphone et
d'aller mendier un peu d'argent à la
province du canton telle province. Alors
ça l'a mis hors de lui. Il a fait une
réforme fiscale. Il a réussi à mettre en
place
fiscale dans lequel il a inversé les
choses. C'est-à-dire que désormais les
impôts étaient collectés par le
gouvernement central qui redistribuit
une partie aux provinces. La conséquence
de ça, c'était les provinces qui ont
commencé à avoir des problèmes
budgétaires. Et alors à ce moment-là,
ces provinces ont adopté ce qu'on
appelle le modèle de Hong
Kong parce que c'est comme ça que
fonctionne le budget Hong Kong depuis
des dizaines d'années. C'est que pour
équilibrer le budget, ce que fait Hong
Kong c'est que il met en vente des
terrains et c'est avec le produit de ces
terrains qu'il arrive avec budget. Donc
les provin Chinois ont commencé à
parître, elles ont commencé à vendre des
terrains à des promoteurs immobiliers.
Et alors à ce moment-là, il y a un
espèce de cercle vicieux qui s'est
engagé, c'est-à-dire que vous aviez une
collusion entre trois entité, d'une
part qui avaient intérêt à vendre les
terrains le plus cher possible pour
effectivement avoir des rentrées
fiscales les plus importantes
possible et à ce moment-là, ils
vendaient les terrains le plus cher
possible. les les promoteurs immobiliers
quand ils achetaient des terrains très
chers, ben ils construisaient des
immeubles très chers de bureaux,
d'habitations qui étaient très très
chers. Bon et ça les arrangeait parce
que il pouvaient gagner plus d'argent
sur des immeubles plus chers et euh
comment se finançait-il ? est financé
d'une part en prévendant les immeubles.
Donc comme la chinois moyen a une épinte
considérable et que le chinois moyen
pense que l'immobilier est un excellent
emplacement, il n'a aucune difficulté à
acheter de l'immobilier. Et par
ailleurs, les promoteurs immobiliers
s'appuyaient sur les crédits bancaires
et les banques chinoises depuis des
généralations ont l'idée que à partir du
moment où on a un collatéral donc qui
est de l'immobilier, c'est du solide.
Donc c'est cette collusion entre les
gouvernements, les banques et les
prteurs immobiliers qui fait que cette
bulle immobilière s'est développée,
s'est développé, sveloppé et a notamment
donné naissance à ce que vous appelez
les costandes. Les villes fantômes. Les
villes fantômes Oui. Oui. Mais ces
villes fantôtes, c'estàdire des villes
avec rien dedans. Ce sont des villes
donc dans lesquelles donc quand les
problers se débrouillent bien, les
immeubles sont vendus mais personne n'y
habite. Et et c'est ça le grand problème
de la Chine, c'est que je disais tout à
l'heure que la consommation chinoise est
faible, elle fait 36 % du
PIB. Donc l'épargne chinoise est
considérable. Et le grand problème,
c'est que 70 % de l'éparne chinoise est
immobilisé dans de l'immobilier.
Et c'est ça une des réformes que le
chinois essaie de faire, c'est-à-dire de
faire en sorte que une partie de
l'argent donc qui est gelé dans
l'immobilier puisse se mettre en bourse
et puisse notamment financer
l'innovation. Donc ça c'est la grande
réforme à venir de la Chine. Bon, on va
Everground, on verra ça plus tard.
Question internet.
À quoi servent les nombreux les
nombreuses infrastruct infrastructures
de transfert technologique visibles par
satellite entre la Chine et la Corée du
Nord ? Comment la Corée du Nord qui
n'arrive même pas à s'éclairer la nuit
arrive à fabriquer des missiles
nucléaires intercontinentaux
? Est-ce que la Corée du Nord c'est un
peu ilvant le fou de la Chine ?
Euh alors je je n'ai pas la la réponse
j'ai pas de réponse document à cette
question.
J'ai mis une hypothèse, j'observe la
Corée du Nord et la la alors la Corée du
Nord avec son dirigeant Kim donc qui est
un espèce de Donald Trump coréen. Ben de
même que Donald Trump c'est quelqu'un
qui qui est loin d'être aussi idiot
qu'on veut bien le croire.
et Kimong
réussit un un numéro quand même tout à
fait extraordinaire. Comme vous l'avez
dit, il dépend complètement de la Chine.
Bon, comment fait-il pour avoir un
espace de liberté ? Et bien, vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé. Il s'est
rapproché de la Russie jusqu'à fournir
des armes, des soldats à la Russie.
Donc en fait la la Corée du Nord depuis
la fin de la guerre du Corée a toujours
réussi à garder un certain espace de
liberté en jouant de la Chine contre la
Russie et de la Russie contre la
Chine.
Donc il est quand même en terme de
géostratégie quand même très fort. Donc
le dirigeant nord est une catastrophe.
Enfin la Corée du Nord c'est une
véritable catastrophe. Mais sur le plan
géostratégique est quand même très fort
parce que il a réussi à à jongler et à
établir une espèce d'équilibre entre la
Chine dont il dépend et et il sait euh
la la Corée du Nord sait que la Chine ne
va pas laisser tomber. Euh donc pour des
raisons géostratégiques, la la la Chine
ne peut pas ne peut pas plus laisser
tomber la Corée du Nord que les
États-Unis ne peuvent laisser tomber
Israël. Donc alors les deux pays sont
différents. Donc je veux pas faire
l'injure à Israël de la comparer à la
Corée du Nord, mais vous voyez euh il y
a quand même un certain nombre de de
points sur lesquels je fais un parallèle
en terme de tête de pont.
Ah non pas en terme en terme de pays
tampon. De pays tampon. OK.
La dissuasion nucléaire nord-coréenne
vous l'évaluez comment ? Est-ce que ils
veulent mettre
le fouttoir dans la région en bombardant
les bases américaines, les Japonais ou
il pratiquent la un starfish prime ? Pas
pas du tout. Vous connaissez Starfish
Prime ? Le Starfish Prime ? Non, je
connais pas. C'est c'est faire décoller
un missile balistique vertical terrain
et ioniser toute la ionosphère et cramer
tous les satellites. Bon non, c'est
c'est les Américains, ils connaissent
très très bien ça. Bon, écoutez moi moi
mon
sentiment que c'est pas tout à fait ça.
C'est euh c'est que la la Corée du Nord
a a appris en fait de l'Irak et de la
Libye.
Quand ils ont vu le sort de Saddam
Hussein et le sort de Kaddafi, ils ont
compris que s'il n'avaient pas enfin ce
qui a causé la mort de Saddam comme de
Kadfi, c'est fait qu'il n'avit pas
l'arme nucléaire. S'ils avaient l'arme
nucléaire, les choses se seraient
passées différemment. Donc c'est pour
moi la Corée du Nord a essentiellement
appris cette leçon quoi. Bon alors ceci
dit la technologie ne marche pas très
très bien. Les les les les missiles sont
pas très pas précis. Il paraît que là,
ils viennent de couler un destroyer.
Enfin, je sais pas très bien ce qu'il en
est. Bon, ils sont pas nécessairement
extrêmement efficaces mais ils possèdent
l'arme nucléaire. Starfish Prime, faut
pas besoin d'être très efficace en terme
de
vecteur. Voyez les les nord coréen sont
quand même très parce que vous parlez de
hackers tout à l'heure, je crois bien
que les hackers les plus performants au
monde sont à Corée du Nord ou en Chine
ou ou en Chine. Euh j'entends surtout
parler de Corée du Nord donc quand il
s'agit de quand il s'agit enfin que vous
avez de de grands scam là comme on dit
donc beaucoup prenent naissance en
grille du nord. Voà, il y a Gael qui est
très en forme et j'ai l'impression qu'
il lit dans notre tête. Le système
crossborder interbank payment System
a-t-il comme ambition finale de
remplacer l'hégémonie de Swift pour les
transactions bancaires ?
Alors euh les Chinois font très
attention à
cela. Les Chinois font très très
attention à ne pas toucher l'hégémonie
du dollar.
tous les tous les euh aux dirigeants
chinois avec lesquels j'ai eu euh
l'occasion de parler. Vous avez parlé à
Sijingping ? Euh j'ai rencontré Simp, je
lui ai pas parlé donc vous l'avez vu
quoi ? Oui, je l'ai vu quoi mais j'ai
bon je veux dire c'est pas avec City
Ping que je vais apprendre le plus de
choses faire mon niveau mais je
rencontrais des gens à niveau comme on
dit N- X là donc vous avez rencontré le
ministre des finances
l'actuel ministre des finances chinois
non quelqu'un d'extraordinaire brillant
le ministre des affaires étrangères
Ah oui le ministre des affaires
étrangères alors je n'ai pas rencontré
non plus brillant ici donc Mais c'est un
c'est un vieux briscard effectivement.
Il est pas si vieux que ça.
Ah non, il il est très
âgé. L'actuel ministre, vous savez que
l'actuel ministre étrangère he je
confonds avec son porte-parole.
Ah c'est pas bon mais je reviens votre
question là sur ce que je veux dire
c'est que tous les tous les responsables
haut niveau me disent que les Chinois
sont convaincus que s'ils attaquaient
vraiment les gémonies du dollar ce
serait un casus béli pour les
États-Unis.
Vous avez même un colonel chinois qui a
écrit tout un essai pour expliquer que
la véritable raison de la guerre d'Irak
était justement que que Saddam Hussein
voulait remplacer le dollar par le le
pétrodollar par l'euro dollar par
l'eurodollar le pétro euro ou l'euro
pétro ou bon donc les g font très
attention et donc se gardent bien
d'attaquer les géomies du dollar pour
différentes raison ne serait-ce que
parce que eux-mêmes possède beaucoup de
dollars. C'est une arme de guerre les
stocks de dollars chinois.
C'est c'est pas vraiment c'est pas
vraiment une arme de guerre parce que
justement c'est une arme nucléaire que
ils vont pas que que personne utilisé.
Et vous savez que maintenant la Chine
n'est plus le n'est plus le plus grand
détenteur de dollars. C'est le Japon. Le
le Japon a 1000 milliards de dollars, la
Chine n'a plus que 800 milliards. La la
Chine a eu un se dépô jusqu'à 1400
milliards de dollars. Donc elle n'a plus
que 800 milliards de de dollars. C'est
le Japon qui avec 1000 milliards de
dollars est le plus grand détenteur de
de de d'obligation américaine. Mais en
revanche, ce que la Chine veut, c'est
mettre en place des systèmes de secours
qui permettent à ce moment-là de prendre
la relève et et de permettre de de de de
continuer à à fonctionner, même si il y
a un gros accident qui se passe sur le
sur le dol de dollars. Vous savez, ils
veulent sortir, ils veulent sortir de de
la capacité des États-Unis à les mettre
sous sanction. Voilà, c'est ils veulent
échapper à la
possibilité, ils veulent
échapper au alors vous avez une
expression que que City utilise beaucoup
en terme de
technologie. En chinois, il dit crap.
Crapose, ça veut dire des technologies
qui étranglent. Moi moi la traduction
que je donne c'est technologie garoto,
c'est-à-dire des technologies qui si
elles sont serrées par une puissance
étrangère et les États-Unis ferait que
la Chine serait garotée quoi, serait
étranglée. D'où la création de la route
de la soie quand les Chinois ont vu la
sécurisation du collier de perle.
C'est c'est alors c'est c'est pas
mon c'est pas mon impression la route
pour moi la route de la soie c'est c'est
quoi les colliers de perles ? Pardon ?
C'est quoi la route du collier de perles
? Donc cé de perle c'est c'est autre
chose. Le coué de perle une route
maritime, c'est une route maritime. Non,
c'est pas une route maritime. Le cé de
perle euh son c'est toute une série
d'îes donc que qu'on appelle celle perle
qui sont les îles qui sont revendiquées
par toute une série de pays dont la
Chine donc notamment en mer de Chine du
sud et qui sont effectivement
stratégiquement importantes. Bon donc
c'est c'est c'est ça qu'on appelle pour
le commerce.
pas seulement pour le commerce, pour
pour la stratégie, pour tout pour tout
une série de pour tout une série de
choses
quoi.
Donc bon,
question internet, ce sera la dernière
ou l'avant-dernière. Comment la Chine va
évaluer évoluer sa voit évoluer sa
démographie se perçoit-elle souveraine
sur l'alimentation et l'énergie de sa
population ?
ça être un problème en Chine. Non, c'est
une grande c'est une grande question ces
questions géographiques.
Mais donc ce qui me frappe c'est que
tout le monde dit bah la Chine comm une
grande erreur avec la démographie, la
politique de l'enfant unique et cetera,
vous savez mais personne ne se demande
pourquoi la Chine a mis en place cette
politique de l'enfant unique. Je vous
rappelle les raisons, c'est parce que
vous vous savez vous rappelez enfin
c'est plus de votre âge parce que vous
êtes trop jeune mais moi quand j'étais
beaucoup plus jeune il il y avait une
chanson de de du tron qui était célèbre
retour de ma veste 1 2 c'est non c'était
700 millions de Chinois et moins et moin
mois vous connaissez cette chanson c'est
une chanson de de du tron qui date si je
ne me trompe de 1966 66. Donc en 1966,
il y avait 700 millions de Chinois.
Maintenant, il y en a 1 400 millions.
Donc vous voyez la la façon dont la
population chinoise peut s'accroître.
Et la Chine estime que compte tenu de sa
taille, déjà la la Chine euh représente
représentait à peu près euh un/art de la
population mondiale à cette époque avec
simplement 20 % des des terres
cultivables du monde. Donc il y avait
déjà une surcharge, un stress important
pour la terre chinoise. Et la Chine a
estimé à partir de là que bien ça ne
pouvit plus continuer. Il y avait une
limite qui ne fallait pas dépasser,
faute de quoi on ne pouvait plus nourrir
la population chinoise. Je vous fais
remarquer que face à ce problème donc
vous avez deux pays qui ont eu de
réponses très très différentes. Ce
problème s'est posé au Japon dans les
années 30 et vous savez qu' a été
réponse du Japon. Le Japon c'est la
théorie de l'espace vital. Ils ont
envoyé le reste de l'Asie pour dire bah
nous n'avons pas assez d'espace pour
faire vivre les Japonais donc on a
besoin de conquérir des territoires
ailleurs. Mais la réponse à la Chine a
été l'inverse de dire bon ben on peut
pas nourrir notre population et bien on
va faire diminuer notre population d'où
la politique de l'enfant unique. Donc il
faut bien voir que sa politique de
l'enfant unique c'est quand même une
politique destinée à assurer la paix et
qui montre justement le fait que la
Chine ne voulait pas envahir les autres
pays. encore une armée suffisamment
costaud, une économie suffisamment
costaud, des réserves de dollars à
suffisamment costaud, une intelligence
artificielle suffisamment costaud pour
pouvoir s'amuser à aller taquiner ses
voisins. Oui, mais encore une fois, je
je je reviens à Chun, donc je reviens en
1420, la Chine avait tout cela avait une
technologie qui était très super au
reste du monde et cetera. Elle n'a
néanmoins pas envoyé le reste du monde
si vous voulez. Donc culturellement, il
y avait pas de désir des Chinois
d'envest du monde. Donc ça cette
politique d'enfant unique était destinée
à freiner la population, faire diminuer
la population chinoise pour éviter
d'avoir des problèmes de surpopulation
et des problèmes de famille. Mais en
effet, la conséquence est que
actuellement, il y a en effet un
problème qui se pose. Plus de petite
chinoise euh plus de petites chinoises.
Oui. Vous vous vous faites allusion à à
la disproportation entre les garçons et
les filles. Alors, écoutez, euh c'est
c'est à la fois vrai et et ça l' de
moins en moins parce que cette
préférence euh pour les garçons est
surtout vraie pour les campagnes et la
population rurale est toujours très
importante. La populationale fait à peu
près 600 millions de personnes, donc sur
les 1ARD4 millions. Donc bon, petite et
et la population est en train de
s'urbaniser à grande vitesse. Donc cette
préférence accrue pour les filles est
quelque chose qui va quand même petit à
petit disparaître. André, ça fait 2h et
dem qu'on qu'on est en interview. On
pourrait parler de la Chine encore, je
dirais, des siècles et des siècles entre
ses traditions, son
histoire, le bonheur des Chinois,
comment les Chinois sont sympas et et on
pourrait encore en faire 3 heures de
plus ce soir. Mais on arrive à la fin.
Moi, je vais vous demander un petit
plaisir personnel. Je voudrais que vous
me récitiez un verre d'un poème chinois
en chinois et ensuite me donner la
traduction en français. Je vous laisse
choisir dans votre
répertoire
encyclopédique. Alors juste pendant je
vais vous accorder encore une seconde de
plus pour pouvoir chercher dans votre
répertoire. André vous avez quel âge ?
C'est très indiscret. Ah vous n'êtes pas
une femme. Alors je vais vous répondre.
Je suis de l'année du serpent.
Euh vous avez le cette année est l'année
du serpent. Donc ça fait 80 et vous avez
un cycle tous les 12
ans. Voilà, je vous laisse calculer.
Bon, qu'est-ce qu'il est vilain ! Il
nous prend à défaut. Alors maintenant,
un verre, un poème bien sûr. Écoutez,
alors je je vais vous citer. Vous voulez
que je cite en chinois ? En premier,
s'il vous plaît, avec la bonne
prononciation. Je je je vais vous
reciter le le poème plus célèbre de la
littérature chinoise qui est le qui est
le poème donc écrit par Lib donc plus
grand poète de tang
donc alors traduction donc devant mon
lit le clair de lune se du givre
Je lève ma tête vers l'astre des nuits.
Je baisse ma tête en pensant au pays
natal. Alors, explication de cela, Lib
était un poète donc vagabond qui était
né dans le nord de la Chine, donc là où
la température est très froide et il
était exilé dans le sud de la Chine. Et
en pleine nuit, un jour, enfin une nuit,
il se réveille et il voit le clair de
lune donc devant son lit sursau, il dit
"Ah, serait-ce du givre ? C'est
serait-ce revenu dans mon pays natal ?"
Je lève la tête et j'aperçois que non,
c'est le clair de lune qui illumine ma
chambre et à ce moment-là, je baisse la
tête en pensant au pays natal.
C'est le poème le plus simple et le plus
connu de toute la langue chinoise.
Je voudrais maintenant que vous nous
conseiller trois livres à lire qui ont
été importants pour
vous. Sur la Chine, j'imagine. Ouais.
sur ce que vous voulez hein.
Écoutez euh
des livres importants pour vous, pas
obligatoirement sur la Chine.
Ben écoutez, je alors comme je suis un
peu polarisé sur la Chine, je vais
donner trois livres qui me paraissent
très très importants. Bon euh un premier
livre, c'est euh les livres enfin sur
les livres écrits par un philosophe
français qui a beaucoup beaucoup
influencé, c'est François Julia. Donc
François Julien, n'importe quel livre de
François Julien sur la Chine, le détour
relaxé, euh l'immanence, la donc les
transformations silencieuses, n'importe
quel
livre est une découverte extraordinaire.
Donc les livres de François Julien sur
la Chine. Ensuite, notre livre beaucoup
marqué, c'est le livre écrit par Henry
Kissinger qui s'appelle de la Chine en
China qui absolument remarquable parce
que c'est un livre écrit à deux mains
dans lequel Henrier a fait travailler un
de ses étudiants absolument remarquable
qui a fait un essai sur la Chine qui est
phénoménal et dans lequel Henrique, il
s'est pas caché d'ailleurs qu'il a fait
travailler quelqu'un mais dans lequel il
a rajouté sa touche personnelle et son
expérience absolument extraordinaire de
la diplomatie et relation avec la Chine.
Et un troisème livre qui est un livre
donc français écrit
par un un français donc qui est euh un
livre écrit par Alexis de Tokville. Donc
euh alors c'est pas de la démocratie en
Amérique que tout le monde connaît,
c'est
donc l'ancien régime et la
révolution. L'ancien régime et la
révolution qui est un essai absolument
extraordinaire.
d'Alex Tocuville où il décrit les
origines de la révolution et comment on
est arrivé à l'empire et où finalement
la la portée de de son analyse est
tellement puissante qu'elle s'applique
aussi à la Chine. André, je voudrais un
conseil pour les jeunes générations. Une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable pour les jeunes. Enfin
donc mon enfin ce dans quoi j'ai
toujours été
élevé toute ma vie c'est et que mon père
m'a demandé n'arrête jamais d'étudier
quel que soit ton âge. Je réponds j'ai
72 ans. Je continue à étudier et je
continue à apprendre. André merci
c'est moi qui remerci.
[Musique]